[Applaudissements]
ok attention j'ai de tahiti des parents
et carlos
d'après la formule chemise basket commun
rigolez pas parce que
je n'aime pas les pions en plus
[Musique]
oh
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chers amis
chers ennemis
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission ou
avec nous ce soir la belle-soeur du
charme à ben laden
les connards
un chat bajon palombes
michaël youn vincent et benjamins
elena lenina
djamel bouras
man bridging
benjamin violée
victime d'un pédophile il raconte dans
un livre bouleversant
chabbert
et le blue jays de jean claude sylvestre
j'accueille maintenant car même ben
laden
[Musique]
bonsoir
alors carmen been made in comme vous
dites vous êtes la belle-soeur donc
d'oussama ben laden
pourquoi avoir pris been la dinepa ben
laden c'est comme ça que le compère de
maisons pour l'écrivaine et certains
frères l'ont changé à sa mort j'aime
bien carmen ben laden oui comment
réagissent les gens à votre à votre nom
hier en venant à paris le 2 nîmes n'a
raté oui à regarder sur son computer
aller est allé derrière train de
téléphoner et pour finir une malaise
s'est passé malgré que je ne passe
poursuit ce qui facilite quand même
d'avoir le passeport 6 avec le nom ben
laden ce n'est pas tout à fait la même
chose que d'avoir un tasseau saoudien
avec
j'ai perdu beaucoup d'amis après le 11
septembre
je crois que c'était je pense que ce
n'est pas vraiment d des amis alors vous
apparteniez à une famille des plus
prestigieuses d'arabie saoudite
aujourd'hui ben laden vous êtes un petit
peu devenu une sorte de deux parias non
mais aussi way entre autres du difficile
je crois qu'elle pour mes fils est très
très difficile c'est très difficile
parce que cette 1ère nous réalisons que
c'est un nom auquel on peut pas
s'échapper c'est à dire changer le nom
ne me sens rien ne changerait rien on
dirait toujours même j'ai vraiment
conscience que même s'il de masse des
jeunes filles si elles se marient et
prennent le nom de leur mari on dirait
toujours tu sais
[Musique]
alors votre fille ou afin était accusé
d'avoir été prévenu du 11 septembre et
d'avoir retardé son retour à new york où
elle vivait alors que votre si en fait
de rentrer et le 15ème viard qu'elle n'a
pas retardé son départ à cause du 11
septembre n'a pas été prévenus à
l'avancé
venu à genève pour l'été et elle était
rentrée pour les vacances ouais
alors quand vous apprenez l'attentât du
world trade center vous êtes dans votre
voiture vous allez de lausanne à genève
avec votre fille wafa justement un ami
vous appelle de new york après l'impact
dans la première tour du world trade
center et avant l'impact du deuxième
avion tout de suite vous pensez que
c'est nous sommes abdelhaleem voix de
nos frères
je me souviens très bien la première
quand il m'a dit attends il ya un autre
avion et mon dieu il rentre dans un dans
la second tour
et moi ma première réaction c'était
mon dieu leur nom va être partout dans
les journaux j'ai pas pensé aux femmes
âgées pas penser j'ai diminué leur nom
va être partout dans les journaux alors
je souhaitais vraiment inquiète alors
quand même ben laden vous publié chez
michel lafon le voile déchirée ou vous
racontez votre histoire alors votre
mariage avec l'un des frères donc
d'oussama ben laden les neuf ans que
vous avez passé en arabie saoudite dans
le clan ben laden
vos rencontres avec votre beau-frère
oussama est votre combat pour fuir tout
ça avec vous trois filles alors on va
prendre les choses par le par le
commencement votre mère donc est issu de
l'aristocratie iranienne elle avait mis
sa famille devant le fait accompli en
fait en épousant secrètement à paris
monsieur dufour citoyens suisses
rencontré à lausanne pendant ses études
évitez quoi votre père homme d'affaires
alors vos parents se sont séparés quand
vous étiez très jeunes avaient eu plus
aucun contact avec votre père votre
maire a pris soin de le rendre ça tout à
fait étanche quoi voilà alors votre
maire elle est née musulmane n'était pas
très pratiquante un nom mais le jeu suit
pas le ramadan
le prix n'est pas très souvent
je suis arrivé en arabie saoudite je
sais toujours pas prier je ne remets pas
prier
allah au printemps 1973 vous êtes
agenaise donc vous vivez à l'époque avec
votre mère est malheureusement plus
votre père il ya beaucoup de touristes
saoudiens qui viennent à un genève pour
l'été vous devez partir en vacances en
iran dans la famille de votre mère et
votre mère sous loue un étage de sa
maison donc quand vous n'êtes pas là aux
frères d'oussama ben laden qui s'appelle
et cela mène la laine donc et puis vous
tombe follement
amoureuse de lui voilà vous partez
suivre ensemble vos études aux usa et
aux usa vous découvrez l'importance de
la famille ben laden c'est que en
arrivant là bas y'a des gens
l'université qui vous ont dit mais c'est
des gens extrêmement puissant
extrêmement important oui j'ai rencontré
un étudiant saoudien qui était dans ma
classe parler qui est qui et diamé
avec les scanners l'ademe le cheikh
hamad était quelqu'un de tout y était
très respecté en arabie saoudite
et qu'il avait beaucoup aidé et c'est là
où j'ai réalisé 1 vous savez à l'époque
personne ne parlait de
y avait pas encore eu le choc pétrolier
dans une arabie saoudite qui n'était pas
l'arabie saoudite actuelle et il était
plutôt prestigieux aux yeux des
saoudiens alors le mariage a lieu en
arabie saoudite vous auriez préféré
genève mais vous n'avez pas vous avez
pas gain de cause et là en arrivant vous
découvrez la bahia c'est à dire qu'on
vous habille de la balle ya en vous vous
en rendez pas compte mais vous regardez
votre soeur salomé et vous découvrez
qu'en fait on va même pas ses yeux
quoique c'est complètement envoyez rien
ct ct et j'avais pris le voile à la
manière je l'avais je l'avais fait à
genève et c'était vraiment très épais
très opaque
oui c'est
le voir c'était au début pour moi
c'était quelque chose d'amusant c'était
quelque chose vous savez comme moi je
porte le voile ce qui ce qui plaît quand
je suis arrivé ce que je dis est ce
qu'on m'avait dit qu'il n'y avait rien
pas de théâtre pas de deux
deux librairies pas de cinéma pas de
restaurant et de l'entente vous dis dans
mon cas il n'ya pas mais vous l'imaginez
passé comme vous êtes là ce que vous
imaginez qu est-ce que c'est vraiment
non il n'y a vraiment rien là vous
découvrez donc la vie des femmes en
arabie saoudite évidemment confinées à
la maison
ne devant pas être vu par des hommes
extérieurs à la famille et même quand
vous allez dans le jardin chez vous les
employés s'en vont pour pas vous voir
toi ma belle mère avait un chauffeur
parce que bien sûr les femmes ne
conduisait pas un avis aux audits qui
l'amenait d'une maison à l'autre et le
chauffeur n'avait jamais vu le visage de
ma belle mère alors que vous en faites
après quelques temps le chauffeur voit
votre visage
bien plus tard tout à fait voilà donc
une drôle de vie avec les journaux qui
arrive caviardé avec des traits noirs
consensus la première fois que j'étais
encore là-bas tout est pêché à la
promenade c'est un péché la musique
c'est un péché la danse c'est un péché
l'art heureusement votre mari vous
traite pas comme ses frères traitent
leurs femmes et effectivement vous vous
participez à l'époque à un semblant de
modernisation en arabie saoudite on
allait encore là dans les supermarchés
voilée et tout et je me suis toujours
demandée par exemple comment parce que
je sortais du supermarché mon chauffeur
savez ils venaient exactement se mettre
à côté de moi et j'étais sous la voie à
l'échelon national
c'était vraiment
surprenant c'est surprenant non ça
c'était avant la chute du chah d'iran et
l'arrivée de commenee donc à téhéran
après il ya eu un véritable retour en
arrière si on vous dit que les femmes
ont été obligées de porter non seulement
des abayas mais des bas noirs sous les
abayas pourquoi qu'on voit un petit bout
de leur cher ce qui était obligatoire
c'est-à-dire en dehors de c'était
l'émeute à voile la police religieuse
et où il avait été peut-être une année
plutôt un peu plus laxistes c'est à dire
qu'il nous faisait pas sortir des
magasins au moment des prières et j'ai
senti un certain laxisme à ce moment là
de nouveau on nous faisait ressortir des
magasins les magasins étaient fermés on
devait relever lire les magasins
devaient être fermés les gens mais il
est encore maintenant en arabie saudite
à l'heure de la prière les magasins son
charme les gens sortent et en général
vous savez où vous attendez dans les
voitures en tout cas moi j'ai
j'attendais dans la voiture avec mon
chauffeur jusqu'à un quart d'heure
jusqu'à que la prière c'est terminé je
retournais dans le magasin alors à ce
moment là vous découvrez que vos filles
subissent des influences néfastes
présent vous découvrez que sur un cahier
en roller a fait écrire je hais les
juifs j'aime la palestine alors vous
vous êtes choqués évidemment partie à
l'école de l'alcool c'est très bien
isolée à l'école et je leur ai demandé
si messi prenait des cours de géographie
parce qu'en soirée cet homme il m'a dit
nous ne nous en donne les cours des jeux
et caf hier dix ans alors je dis s'il
appelle ma fille et je lui demande de
montrer sur la carte la palestine est ce
qu'elle sera aussi le mot dit non non
non je vous dis à 11 ans dont selon lui
apprenez à lire quelque chose qu'elle
n'arrivait même pas à placer sur la
carte que vous allez voir la directrice
de l'école qui vous dit vous n'y
comprenez rien toute façon vous êtes une
étrangère et cette phrase terrible elle
vous dit est ce que votre mari est au
courant de votre démarche c'est à dire
que c'est avec moi parce que j'ai je me
suis et comment dire
j'ai essayé de lui expliquer que je ne
voulais pas que mes filles haïssent
quelqu'un sur la base de leur religion
2le et je lui ai même dit si un jour je
peut à la rigueur accepter que ma fille
ait quelqu'un mais je voudrais qu'elle
ait au moins une bonne raison et je là
elle me dit à court d'arguments elle se
retourne vers moi elle me regarde comme
ça elle dit est ce que votre mari est
courant ici et j'étais furieuse je lui
ai dit écoutez mon mari va vous
téléphoner je suis rentré à la maison et
j'ai dit à sam si tu appelles pas
cette personne je ne resterai pas essai
et il a téléphoné à vous finissez par
partir de là bas en 85 vous installer en
suisse donc votre marié vous le sentez
un petit peu de s'éloigner de s'éloigner
de vous à ce moment là et vous découvrez
qu'il vous trompe un soir où balader
dans jeunet avec votre voiture et vous
voyez s'en tire avec ça avec sa
secrétaire de son bureau
je crois que ça peut arriver ça mais sa
réaction plus tard c'est à dire que sa
réaction m'a fait penser beaucoup plus à
une réaction
d'un homme saoudien que c'était très
normal bon
alors vous vous êtes plus jamais
retournés en arabie saoudite depuis
karman a joué bas parce que comme votre
mari vous a accusé d'adultère la macif
c'est passible de la peine de mort je
sais qu'en arabie saoudite et ça je le
sais il n'a pas besoin de moi pour
divorcer mais
alors j'assume qui m'a prise et
d'adultère au lieu de quoi aujourd'hui
j'ai une pension alimentaire qui était
je suis ce qu'on appelle enfuis sur
mesure provisoire c'est à dire que le
juge
me donne
pour subvenir à mes besoins beaucoup non
non par rapport à ceux qui gagnent sans
pilote s'est pas beaucoup non exactement
alors votre mari a beaucoup d'argent il
ya quand même énormément de sociétés
offshore vous dites 75 et c'est
quelqu'un qui quand même lié au commerce
international aux flux financiers
internationaux d'une façon un peu opaque
il a d'ailleurs tenté de faire interdire
en suisse un livre ça peut être la
vérité interdite de dasquié brizard
qu'on a reçu ici l'année dernière et
puis le juge van ruymbeke a fait
perquisitionner sa villa cannoise savez
la bergerie sur une enquête donc de
blanchiment blanchiment d'argent est ce
que vous pensez qu'à travers de ces
circuits financiers un petit peu opaque
donc la famille ben laden et votre mari
entre autres continuent à soutenir
financièrement oussama ben laden je
pense qu'il ya
énormément de gens en arabie saoudite
qui soutient tous les causes islamistes
je ne pense pas vous savez je ne suis
pas en train de dire que si
si oussama ou quelqu'un comme oussama
vient dire j'ai besoin d'argent pour
faire sauter une ambassade on va lui
donner de l'argent mais s'il vient mais
ils disent vous savez je vais faire 3 ou
4 madrid sa
mosquée
séoul a valu le donner on ne va pas
hésiter à lui le débat pas regarder ce
qui fait du pognon je vous dis dans
votre bouquin qu'il est très très proche
le d'abdallah qui est le prince héritier
d'arabie saoudite c'est une chose que
j'ai que mon mari me l'a dit je me
souviens très bien mais je ne dis pas
que toute la famille royale le soutien
mais je pense que comme
il y à des membres de la famille royale
qui qui qui sont tout à fait d'accord
avec eux avec sa main du reste vous
savez donc pour beaucoup d'arabes j'ai
eu l'occasion de parler ils disent
qu'ils étaient la preuve qu chemin a été
impliqué dans ces attentats n'existe pas
et quand il parle de cette base la x bow
et les occidentaux l'accusent centre
mais la revendiquer quand même ils
disent que d'après j'ai eu une
conversation justement avec quelqu'un
qui m'a dit oh non mais vous vécu ces
avec la technologie moderne on peut on
peut faire dire n'importe quoi sur
cet argent il est transmis comment vous
pensez si c'est pas par des banques sans
liquide non bien sûr vous savez moi à
coacher en arabie saoudite ou dans les
pays du moyen-orient tout se passe les
gens utilisent beaucoup de cash
il n'y a pas de traces à l'époque je
n'ai jamais eu des carnets de chèques en
arabie saudite je n'ai jamais eu de
winne de diabète et de l'argent oui
j'avais
est ce que vous croyez que ça m'a ben
laden est toujours en vie je suis
persuadé qu'il est en vie parce que je
pense que c'est quelque chose était
arrivée à ossama la famille le ferai
savoir oui pour faire baisser la
pression qu'ils auront ce qu'ils ont sur
eux pour être un peu plus tranquille
alors maintenant la question à 25
millions de dollars
ça va si jeunesse savait et on peut se
partager le pognon
viléo je ne sais pas il peut être
partout ouais on arrondit qu'ils
ont dit qu'ils étaient au pakistan ou en
afghanistan dans les zones tribales à la
frontière entre pakistan et en
afghanistan
j'ai aucune idée sinon 25 millions de
dollars
voilà vous raconter tout ça donc dans un
bouquin qui s'appelle le voile déchirée
vous rencontrez évidemment aussi vous
vous rencontre avec oussama ben laden
alors il ya extraordinaire un jour vous
êtes athée y est je crois il fait super
chaud
et puis moi ici contrairement à ici
voulu qu'on baisse la clim s'il vous
plaît si on peut baisser un petit peu la
clim parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
le climat de la messaoudi de ce soir
donc un jour des matériels qu'il fait
très chaud vous voyez la femme d'oussama
ben laden qui nourrit leurs enfants à la
petite cuillère avec de l'eau avec de
l'eau alors vous dites pourquoi pas mais
bon j'ai offert bon du moment elle la
refuse et je ne comprenais pas et je me
rappelle jeudi en appel mer mais cet
enfant restait déshydraté pourquoi il
lui donne pas le biberon et au début
j'ai naïvement je croyais que je lui dis
mais un mouvement est stabilisée et et l
ai dit nono sa marque fisc et nous
sommes à voulait pas quoique l'enfant et
du caoutchouc dans la bouche dans la
pièce ouais et j'ai fait appeler il ya
seulement dix ans écoutent va parler
avec ton frère parce que cet enfant va
céder et traite des et raté les mains et
il est revenu en me disant non ils
refusent catégoriquement
mais pourquoi diable le caoutchouc sais
pas c'est peut être le cas où tu peux
pas être interdit par le coran puisque
ce n'est pas du temps de mao même cas où
tu es maintenant je ne sais pas je
comprenais pas non plus jugé non chamard
refuse que son bien son fils prend le
biberon alors en descendant cet incident
m'a marqué parce que c'était aux chemins
c'est cet incident on m'a marqué parce
que pour la première fois j'ai réalisé
le poids de la parole d'un homme même
s'il n'était pas dans la pièce
et que toutes ces femmes et moi on était
impuissante à faire quoi que ce soit et
et tout le longue du retour dans la
voiture
je
j'ai pensé mon dieu c'est quelque chose
à l'époque tout allait bien entre mon
mari et moi et moi j'avais quand même
beaucoup de facilité c'est à dire que
mon mari les enfants étaient plus petits
accepté ma manière d'éduquer les enfants
et j'ai eu une angoisse profonde en me
disant mais si quelque chose arrivait à
guillaume est un don un de ses frères
devenait un sur le tuteur les enfants
et là c'était bon peur wen ont cessé la
première ce qu'on me dit en anglais le
premier cap corse oui vous avez rêvé
qu'elle révèle alarme l'alarmé qui ne
m'a plus jamais quitté et je crois que
c'est à partir de ce moment là où j'ai
commencé à observer pour les petits
détails de l'arabie saudite les tout ce
qui pourrait
tout ce qui se passait pour essayer
d'analyser de comprendre et c'est
une autre fois aussi où vous croisez
oussama ben laden vous êtes chez vous
dans le jardin on sonne à la porte vous
l'ouvrez sans réfléchir il vous voit
et qu'est-ce qui se passe il se retourne
il était à l'époque devait avoir créé
4 5 ans dans la vingtaine et il me
regarde et je lui il me regarde et se
tourner du sitting quelques secondes il
me fait signe de partir et il me fait
pour ça et je
et je n'ai pas réalisé ce jeu les séries
j'ai dit nono et cela mais là et son
neveu qui était avec lui même a dit ça
ou ça m'a aidé et j'ai réalisé ces nous
sommes alors je suis parti j'ai appelé
ça veut dire qu'oussama il a toujours
été comme ça à quoi depuis son plus
jeune âge il était extrêmement pieux est
alors proposée dont ses frères pour sa
famille il est une sorte de héros
j'imagine parce que il est parti se
battre en afghanistan et tout ça en plus
d'avoir de l'argent il a une espèce de
sacralité un petit peu comme ramed
chèque le père non avant de partir en
afghanistan sa main était un frère comme
les autres et après quand il est parti
en afghanistan pour se battre contre les
soviétiques et il est devenu un héros
pour pas seulement la famille ben laden
pour du mans pour tout le monde tout le
monde
pourquoi vous avez écrit ce bouquin
côté ce bouquin c'est
une explique l'explication d'une mère à
ses filles parce que je sais que
mes filles ont eu un prix émotionnel à
payer pour
parce qu'elle s'appelle ben laden et
pour les décisions que j'ai prises pour
elle c'est à dire que je sais que si
j'avais accepté de suivre les règles
saoudienne et de les élever un peu plus
dans l'est dans la culture saoudienne
peut-être qu'elle n'aurait pas été
rejetés par leur famille et je crois que
ça a été très douloureux pour mes filles
d'être
rejeté par la famille elles ont lu le
bouquin au fait oui elles disent quoi
elles m'ont dit qu'elles aimeraient
fonds ad c'est bien nous ramenons le
média c'est fantastique et c'est très
bien quand vous dites j'ai vécu au sein
du clan ben laden je connais la société
saoudienne et j'ai peur pour l'avenir de
l'humanité c'est-à-dire que vous pensez
que
finalement la culture occidentale ne
peut rien faire finalement face à ces
fondamentalistes prêt à tout vous savez
j'appelle les fondamentalistes une armée
de l'ombre
ils sont là on ne sait pas si vous
regardez les tragédie du 11-septembre
3900 détruit comme ça avec et avec
quelles armes un avion donc vous prenez
que je prends tout le monde prend et 19
personnes après une année après avoir
passé une année dans une société qui n'a
pas pu les influencer en quoi trésor ont
mis en exécution
ils ont besoin de prendre notre
technologie pour le retourner contre
nous et ça c'est sa maîtresse vous
croyez en l'islam modéré
j'aimerais croire en islam modéré ou ce
qui me fait peur aussi si vous savez
quand je suis allé en au début des
années soixante quatorze en arabie
saoudite l'arabie saoudite était le seul
pays qui étaient sous la halle sur la
charia
et ce quand je regarde tout ce qui s'est
passé
malgré tout toute cette évolution ya eu
dans le monde de plus en plus de pays
demandent et ça ça mettrait iran quand
vous voyez alors
oui je crois qu'il ya parce qu'autrement
ce serait terrible s'il n'y avait pas un
islam modéré soeur ou pensez quoi de la
querelle
du voile à l'école en france
écoutez je
je je trouve que je ne peux pas accepter
qu'en consommant koné a accepté le voile
ici parce que vous savez ça l'utiliser
en arabie saoudite par exemple ils ont
une moitié de la population qui est qui
et étrangères ils ont beaucoup de
philippins deux qui sont de religion
catholique il n'y a pas une seule église
pour d'accord et quand je vois ses
excuses à ces femmes qui descendent dans
la rue et qui revendique 2 le port du
voile dans une société laïque et qui
veulent que nous on oublie notre culture
à nous
et au sens où vous étiez ces femmes
quand il ya encore pas si longtemps il
ya trois ans le régime taliban
étaient en train de prix mais leur chef
pourquoi elles sont pas descendus et
avoir les mêmes revendications pour un
pour un régime qui opprimait normal oui
vous vous pensez quoi vous pensez que
les clés français disons les européens
et occidentaux peu importe vous pensez
qu'ils sont trop finalement faible face
à ça vous pensez que ici le côté
république chacun fait ce qu'il veut ça
redonne trop de possibilités je pense
que je pense qu'on doit être vigilant
qu'il n'utilise pas notre indulgence
pour pour imposer leur intolérance voilà
carmen ben laden donc le voile déchirée
c'est chez michel lafon merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec le débauchage
je mens pas
je déchirée
messieurs michel lamarre
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant la honda fit
on l'a dit
là
m
je vous demande de vous arrêter
au lot no comment ça va ça va j'ai bien
fait de pouvoir le blouson il faut
encore plus fort les écarts mais non là
c'est fort ce 9 s'est pas coupé est-ce
qu'on peut dédier cette émission à ticky
holgado volontiers voilà
[Applaudissements]
volontiers
et moi je voudrais dire bonsoir à kamel
voilà
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
on n'a pas là
[Musique]
mais quand il a lu ça
toi
commune et claironne le brouillard
voici les connards
[Musique]
et les connards mesdames messieurs bon
vous interprétez temps
bonsoir les nrj music awards
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi oui pourquoi
récré où il ajouté
je pense les crottes nina hagen
depuis cette époque avec les bottes pour
les soirées ont fini tous ensemble et
danse
ces deux
il
et k
combien
la monogamie poliquin on aime les chiens
oh
pour le métro sans tiquer aux
tourniquets
wec et les canards toute façon on s'en
fout on les fout on s rachat mais dieu
l'assaut
souvent seule
tabary
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
non
moi
et
[Musique]
sur les bassins
c'est fait
[Musique]
auj
il a le droit comme
[Musique]
yann et en sport
à malaga
non
voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'était comme des canards
interprété par les connards
plaît
c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
je me demande de vous arrêter
vous demande de vous arrêter je vais
vous dire franchement on peut pas en
faire 40 comme ça c'est fort bravo donc
c'est la bande au frais à l'égard de mon
client pleuvent jack bauer
originale du film les 11 commandements
donc comme des connards par la callas on
me dit qu'il faut la refaire pas à ses
péchés
ce qui est écrit ça les paroles ouais
des paroles c'est nous la musique c'est
les nac ce qui avait notamment fait momo
my sharona
[Musique]
ce
défi ap
bush
hier
fillon
l'insolent plagiat dans l'autre sens
ouais c'est que les knacks nous nous on
nous ont plagié mes 12 ans avant sa mort
c'est un groupe néo fin qu'on peut dire
les connards néo néo néo néo beaucoup d
eau d opa est montée haut quelles sont
vos influences musicales zii egg zh
ouais ouais aujourd'hui est celle d'un
wayne white stripes un fayot puis les
vertes et mary madden l'on jette on
voterait comment on était no1 dans un
club échangiste je grossis à chaque fois
réponse à des concerts de musique en
fait toujours un 5e échange islande
est ensemble depuis longtemps les
connards oui trop alors est-ce que vous
avez des envies de carrière solo les
canards
avec le problème c'est que dans déjà
dans le groupe il y en a que deux qui
chantent ouais et les deux qui chante
s'il n'avait pas eu recours à comment on
appelle ça c'est toi qui as you are est
l'auto tune je n'avais pas eu en ayant
les personnes qui changent
merci voilà on voudrais surtout
remercier l'auto tune sans lui on
n'existe pas
les chanteurs qui vont aux nrj music
awards
je n'avais pas les connards musicaux on
va pas aux nrj music awards un chez
ardisson c'est avec samba les couilles
ouais en
fait aux chanteurs de bratislava on me
le dit assez souvent en cuisine je
ressemblais un petit peu alphonse brown
s'est soldée bratislava water qui suit
on sait pas ce qu'ils sont devenus
[Musique]
c'est terrible content qu'il soit mort
cela on sait pas ce qu'ils sont devenus
remarquez quand même que ils ont
progressé depuis musicalement ils se
sont ils ont découvert qu'il buvait
quand même faire un morceau qui paie la
route c'est leur forêt ça c'est pas de
leur faute c'est grâce à lolo jones
ouais ça va cartonner
oui
alors maintenant on va voir si vous êtes
de vrais connards on va faire le
questionnaire de proust
[Musique]
quel est pour vous le comble de la
misère d'être goûteurs chez buffalo dry
n'y croit la star academy
quel est votre idéal de bonheur
terrestre ces chefs d'être dette chez
toi dans ton canapé ouais de foot des
grandes bennes ya ton lien chan
d'insultés ta femme de pas t'occuper de
ton gosse et drogues jardin bataille et
fontaine en se grattant les coins la
pizza pizza pizza
pour quelle faute avez-vous le plus
d'indulgence à faute de goût
quelle est la qualité que vous préférez
chez l'homme sa femme
[Applaudissements]
mais quelle est la qualité vous préférez
chez la femme sa fille
qui auriez-vous aimé est si vous étiez
pas les connards polpot way au maroc
et la qualité que vous appréciez le plus
chez vos amis quand ils s'en vont
quel est votre principal défaut
à moi j'en ai un mais ça va être
compliqué à expliquer je soutiens le
front national oui mais c'est pour des
raisons éminemment politique j'ai décidé
que si nous on soutenait le front
national tous les électeurs du front
national veut goûter ne voulant pas se
reconnaître dans ce vote vont le laisser
tomber à l'eau
on le vit
votre père
[Musique]
l'aficion
les attire c'est une femme
la tête de son sel la taille de son
ce que vous détestez par dessus tout
il sauta toujours des trucs à répondre
tout le temps oui j'ai ma carte de
banquiers mois danger bourse non mes
gardes il faut être là répondre ouais il
à la semaine dernière à deviers joncour
il lui a repris dans la chambre et
regardez regardez chaussures qu'elle lui
a offert
mais bon une pause insultes ah ouais
honneur
comédie
pour une pause bisou à huy
[Musique]
comment aimeriez-vous mourir à
neuilly-sur-seine ou rien moi je veux
mourir à lui je sais ne devance voilà ça
à tence
elle et qu'elle est à présent de votre
esprit à
présent vers
quel est votre devise l'euro
comme tout le monde en fait non notre
vraie nature c'est d'avoir 14 ans merci
conduire une voiture sans toucher au
volant ouais c'est aller droit au but en
soi
connor
verreault
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
weston
en avez vous on ne sera jamais carrasso
on se veut
m non
vous voyez pas dans le coup il dit je
donnais fleurs à bout de nerfs
lellouche
ainsi alain chabat et jean paul rouve
or
alors
jean paul rault mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
laurent merci d'en
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup à saigner
et et et et l'eau et leurs mamans ouais
bonsoir s'il est beau mais là bien sûr
vous à quelques membres françoise
bonsoir c'est jeudi jabbar
deux noms de faire des petits quand même
ses formes il a déclaré à l'ats elle
réussit merveilleusement vous espériez
pas tant qu'entité vous je pensais pas
qu'il était comme un petit
à petit
par ailleurs
de gros un peu plus gros
il avait pas moustaches et l'âme et à la
semaine il avait déjà des tendances au
avec pas les mêmes que maintenant
peut-être qui est aussi maman rappelle
que
tu t'es sorti de l'alcool
en fait pas maintenant parce que
qu'est-ce qui on attend les gens sont
choqués quand vous allez chercher à
l'école quand on était petits c'était
bourré devant les commissions faire de
ça alors il ne faut plus en parler parce
que sa valeur ouais halvick 6 ouais
c'est sûr ils se tirent toujours sur
l'élastique
c'est via pas passer bah oui
à quel âge il a commencé à l'un
j'ai mis un an et demi oui un peu un peu
retardé
c'est plutôt mais c'est vrai qu'il avait
le bouton rouge toujours oui
c'est une île était en veille déjà tout
comme un chien tu sais très arrondi fera
bondir
si ta mère
son père
oui mais également la maman de eric et
ramzy on embrasse sa passagère
mais vous dis au revoir
on va les filles à toute heure
dans la loge après l'émission montre
maintenant par les mamans si
maintenant elle sait qu'à blâmer
ses mots
c'est un grand moment une prévision à
ces bourses mondiales
elle supprime
avec volé ma mère ouais ouais je ne
savais pas qu'elle était goy du nord
norad bien alors vous êtes ici pour la
sortie d'un des films les plus attendus
de l'année qui s'apaise voilà donc c'est
un film écrit par ici ils ont fait
exprès en fait pour ça c'est fait pour
ça morgan hacker servi à acheter les
billets ça sera bon jour jouer une place
pour donc un film qui est écrit par les
robins en collaboration avec alain
chabat joué par les romains et alain
chabat plus depardieu rochefort valérie
lemercier dominique farrugia font des
apparitions pour le mérite aux items
parution voilà et réalisé par alain
chabat alors le pitch je vais le faire
je crois que ce sera beaucoup plus
simple le pitch pas d'abord le fond
c'est le premier thriller préhistorique
nous sommes en pleine préhistoire moins
trente cinq mille ans avant jésus-christ
et pour la première fois un crime est
commis c'est la première fois qu'un
homme tue un autre homme alors pourquoi
tu es qui a tué c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit le premier thriller préhistorique ce
la première fois que va faire se pose
est au niveau de la forme c'est beaucoup
moins métaphysique mais c'est le premier
dessin animé dans les personnages sont
des vrais acteurs je crois qu'on peut le
dire 1 j'aime bien ouais c'est gentil
mais si c'est marina qu'a dit ça
alors là donc et la tribu des cheveux
sales qui veut voler le secret du
shampoing à la tribu des cheveux propres
et ce qu'elle le vaut bien voilà
et alors tout le monde s'appelle pierre
parce qu'on est à l'âge de pierre et
puis les animaux évidemment il ya des
des poules goutte chez les canards
mousse et puis il ya des fermes où tu
qu'on a ici derrière voilà ça c'est une
espèce de petite poule rousse c'est une
poule motlanthe voilà ça c'est quoi ça
ailleurs tout ça c'est un oeil en
cochons moutons
ça c'est le lapin mujibar gimat le lapin
mouthe et puis il ya le foot lorsque
voilà donc ça se passe quand on goûte
ya des mammouths mais pas de mode voilà
c'est porte nawak en fait c'est c'est ou
non s'est basé sur des faits réels
et il ya eu beaucoup de recherches sur
le sur le sujet notamment chasse étant
maintenant retrouver sa grande époque
vous avez retrouvé des documents dits
blancs bien sûr un puisque la couleur
n'existe qu'à l'époque vous voyez donc
forcément les enregistrements d'assez
mauvaise qualité mais qui nous ont quand
même permis de travail et une base une
base coiffe un devoir à la véracité
voilà des bien sûr et beaucoup de drogue
[Musique]
il y a trente cinq mille ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
senda hotahota aux dogues à
rien ce que vous dites mais innover
et où les enfants n'avaient rien de
mieux à faire que de regarder la fresque
allez on éteint la
seule comédie préhistorique de 2004
est aussi la première enquête de tous
les temps sans face à quelque chose qui
n'est jamais arrivé j'appelle ce quelque
chose
il était comment l'idée de vaud fait une
descente au village on arrête tous les
types qui était de dos hier l'inquiétude
qu'elle d'amour dès que tout ça sera
terminé je m'occuperai de toi
les robins des bois
gérard depardieu tout et je crois qu'il
faut raison garder la foi tu vas te le
permet alain chabat
passé un truc là non vous ne marchez sur
les cheveux pardon
en janvier
[Musique]
préparez-vous à retenir
à l'âge de pierre salut pierre la
lumière
mais vous pouvez prononcé rrr aussi si
vous voulez
et un tabac avec alain chabat
parmi les gens
j'aurais clients
l'expert g
jean paul rouve est le personnage du
vous appelez le blond non ma fille tu
m'appeler pierre j'aime pas qu'on
appelle le blond permanence vous sentez
un petit peu différent des autres à la
wii c'est d'ailleurs c'est un film sur
la différence je crois qu'il faut le
dire tout de suite je suis seul blanc de
la tribu et je vis je vis assez mal la
différence pour ça que je joue un
personnage un peu renfermé c'est un peu
un personnage à la clau de sauter dans
le film que j'attends c'est qu'avec
quelque chose quelque chose sauter mais
s'en remit schneider et michel piccoli
mais bon un drame rural
c'est un personnage assez assez épais au
milieu de tout ça un personnage un peu
tourmenté voilà un peu tourmenté c'est
la première fois que je fais ce genre de
personnage je suis très content mais
c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un remarque
ouais mais oui c'est vrai
malheureusement jamais bah voilà ici si
je l'éteins marié fort et j'ai eu du mal
à faire seuls alors ça veut donc c'est
chabal et robin j'ai déjà dit trois fois
sortie nationale le 28 janvier 700
copies sur dans un cinéma près de chez
vous qu'il le joue parce que 700 copies
c'est une arme non
oui oui si on le sert pas de vanne
pas de vannes ouais c'est 100
copies par rapport à
cet office et c'est beaucoup vous
comptez faire quand même entré à la à
peu près avec mon film précédent a fait
14 millions et demi d'entrées devant se
faire doubler ouais donc je pense qu'on
va faire à la
je prends va faire est-ce qu'on va
perdre ce sera plus sûr on va faire
plusieurs prises en juillet vous comptez
faire comme un mantra vous allez me
répondre d'abord 14,6 millions quant à
dire quand même très bas 14,6 millions
la maintenance et me dire 6 millions
vous êtes à combien d'entrés
vous les vrais chiffres non je veux le
chinois puis je prendrai la meilleure
prise en fonction des entrées comme un
nombre est d'accord ça comme ça vous
aurez raison vous aurez toujours présent
en dit moins 6 millions alors je vais
faire comme entre 6 millions 6 millions
mais on a refait encore eu aussi le
maire croit migraine pour moi oui comme
elle entraîne et que dire 2 milliards
alors nous n'aurons pas fait quand même
entrés et ont filmé deux milliards
des milliards de milliards ce sont les
pertes de la production en anciens
francs on en tiendra
[Applaudissements]
maintenant tu vas me faire 180 millions
de ces points communs entre et 180
milles comme d'affilée
alors est-ce que vous attaché de presse
sont là comme ça oui bien sûr je
préfèrerais olivier meriam et myriam
henggi rien mais la très bien que myriam
qu'on va leur faire plaisir on va faire
les questions du dossier de presse comme
ça ou pas il n'y aura pas de vie aura
pas de problème on est sûr que vous vous
rendrez le fit alors comment êtes vous
arrivé sur ce projet alain chabat c'est
amusant que vous me posiez cette
question
comme comme comme producteur d'abord
dominique farrugia qui devait
initialement produire le film a été
appelé pour diriger canal+ bon ce poste
allée lui prendre 120 % de son temps
il m'a donc contact avec les robins des
bois pour savoir si je voulais produire
c'est bien non mais ça fait vraiment de
cinéma logements connaît vraiment le
terrain les gens sont pas habitués à la
spontanéité chez
vous à avoir du plaisir à jouer même
avec la pression de votre double
fonction alain chabat
vous réalisez que vous jouez sur février
mission de cinéma là
c'est une bonne question que personne
n'a jamais posé ça me fait plaisir
ardisson bon j'adore jouer j'adore
réaliser mais c'est vrai que les deux en
même temps n'était pas mon exercice
favori
tout dire les jours où je faisais acteur
réalisateur
gt gt d'une humeur de d'ogm août
c'est très désagréable pour l'équipe
entre parenthèses qu'elle soit remerciée
pour sa patience mais ça m'a bien aidé
pour le rôle très bien
n'aurait-il pas été plus simple de
trouver le film en studio alors on ya
pensé et puis finalement jean rochefort
a accepté ouais
souvenirs garderez-vous de leur
voisine c'est toi j'ai entendu alain au
début la question
alain chabat à quels souvenirs
garderez-vous de haut il y en a beaucoup
tout ce joyeux liés au bonheur de
travailler avec des gens décidés à
donner le meilleur quant aux robins il
travaille autant qu'ils déconnent qui ce
sont de très gros bosseur
george v vous
tue plus occupés par leurs partenaires
et vous et vous et vous et vous attend
son
d'après les figurants
juste après l'été durant le témoignage
de figurants ils font un devoir
jean paul raconte c'est pas ça jean paul
à la plage non plaît jean-paul à l
érection ces paroles
font l'espagne
extraterrestre nom jean pierre leblon
d'attributs machine et vous direz vous
on s'est
excusé moi aussi excusez moi l'école
jean paul pourquoi
dans tout processus d'énergie en vol
[Musique]
nous avions ce temps leur
demandez moi l'adhésion bien dans
l'élite ou sans leurs ou d'un
[Musique]
extrait de la bo du film alors sur la bo
yahia joey starr ya ophélie winter il ya
fabuleux aussi à busta flex il ya
superbus ouais on l'aimé bien c'est les
fans de jenifer et c est bien derrière
le making of en papier alors ça c'est
extraordinaire donc il ya le scénario
semble pour ben voilà ça c'est vraiment
ton fils adorent l'ordre et la bible et
jouit grave il a aussi découvert les
répliques il ya le scénario original il
y avait storyboard je vous dessinez très
bien monsieur chabat merci tient
vraiment et puis à des photos aussi du
tournage enfin ses textures bien maman
nul
et puis j'allais et puis elle et
peluches aussi évidemment les photos des
peluches voix et maintenant
interview sans la bouche
[Musique]
jean-paul
interviews sont la bouche attention ne
dit rien vous êtes dans une soirée
claude berri vous vous salue en vous
appelant jean pierre rives vous êtes
obligé de sourire parce que c'est claude
berri vous souriez comment
alain dans la même soirée nicolas
sarkozy arrive vous salue vous parle
vous félicite un photographe arrive fait
quelle tête sur la photo jean-paul à ce
moment là une sublime gonzesses entre ne
regarde que vous vous êtes inaccessible
fait kate est inaccessible mais pas trop
inaccessible mais pas trop ouais mais
pas trop inaccessible inaccessible je
suis excessivement au patro pas trop
m
à l'ats
nicole kidman arrive dans cette soirée
il ya claude berri déjà nicolas sarkozy
est nécessaire d' asie et l heure l on
voit comment elle fait aïe alan vous
faites quoi vous
le font parce que c'est kidman et que je
vois la vie qu'est ce qui fait que ces
blaireaux
jean-paul vous vous croisez quelqu'un de
visiblement important en fait vous
l'avez pas reconnu c'est le nouveau
comics et alain delon fait quelle tête
l'américaine
j'envoie de jean pierre guérin le
producteur de gilles escot vous racontez
vos débuts dans la série il vous propose
de revenir dans la série julie lescaut à
un million de francs l'épisode pizza
pizza pizza
millions de francs épisode
alors vous embarquez nicole kidman on
est lui lui moi je rencontre jean pierre
guérin julie les frais juste appris que
le team and video marque nicole kidman
ses verrières en même temps vous prenez
votre voiture vous avez pas un dernier
verre au costes et là vous lui dites
nicole contrairement à ce que tout le
monde croit
je ne suis pas d'oran je suis américain
4chan merde ça c'est pour commencer
oui moi quand je fais l'américain je
suis un peu classe fait comme ça que ma
jean-paul
vous quittez la soirée à votre tour vous
en avez marre d'être avec ses rêves
autovision marion gaja
vous allez vous allez au cost ouais si
vous rencontrez alain chabat une colle
kidman qui sont en train de prendre un
dernier verre il fait l'américain
vous vous asseyez vous êtes là tous les
trois ou gacko et d'un seul coup ophélie
winter arrive chez bonjour ophélie même
comme chose dans les cheveux
je peux en parler et là elle me demande
pourquoi pas si c'est un truc ardisson
ne pas dire bonjour normalement sous
toit
mais en bas
devant des gens
valérie lemercier que l'unique bar avec
jeu
josé
michaël youn michael 12 ans de prison
c'est qui la blonde avec vous
ah ouais rappelons que c'est un terme à
la production
comment ça s'est passé avec elles
n'ont pas les 3
et maintenant
[Musique]
non
il
il y a
[Musique]
et je lai
où
m
non
ouais
non non la lutte
voilà
à
alors
c'est cela
segway
chabarot
yves thomas
également arrêtés
qu'est ce qui se passe à la dépendance
sa requête a bougé d'atours tout à
l'heure
le 28 janvier le film ne sort et une
semaine après heureusement vous ne serez
pas en face le mercredi la place pour
tout le monde quand les films sont bien
les gens vont au cinéma oui enfin quant
à nemo le seigneur des anneaux
c'est quelqu'un je tiens c'était des
moules seigneur des anneaux j'étais
parti pour les tous les deux fait
un contretemps voilà
on le 4 février soit huit jours après le
sortir à votre nouveau film qui
s'appelle les 11 commandements produit
par un bennahmias qu'on conseille aux
passagers mon entrée salade bien sûr
vraiment est adorable et très
complaisante
et réalisé par lé real de madrid oui
fameuse équipe d'airé à l'épicerie
record fait les deux réalisateurs
avaient tellement
ils ont préféré similaires
non moi je faire le pitch alors je vous
laisse le dossier
car le pitch alors le monde va mal les
humains ne rigole plus c'est grave le
dieu de la blague dieudonné ça j'avoue
que le tube like the dawn est bon au
port a tué données oui ça n'a plus
qu'une solution donc c'est michaël youn
et sa bande 1 cc alors c'était
l'argument décisif parce que tous les
autres comics est occupé à faire
d'autres films que voilà ou encore
podium voilà qui sortira sept jours
après mais je tiens à dire allez voir
podium parce que c'est un très bon film
et ses sept jours après voilà alors la
mission de michaël youn et sa bande
c'est accomplir les 11 commandements de
la blague et là c'est nouveau c'est que
c'est en vrai sait on ce défi qu'on a
fait en vrai dans la rue tourné caméra
au poing avec des jarres et c'est
nouveau c'est en vrai un origine dans un
égout
la première c'est un peu dans l'esprit
de du morning live de jackass et de tom
green
voilà vous avez tourné tous ces défis
pour de vrai alors vous dit michael dans
ce dossier de presse puisque là ce soir
au reste pour faire plaisir là c'est
pour faire plaisir à enzo enzo qu'on
embrasse
vous qui habitez toulouse vous ne
comprenez rien cette émission ça n'est
pas grave changez lille
ce week end oui vous dites dans le
dossier de presse on me proposait des
comédies traditionnel mais j'ai le temps
pour le traditionnel je voulais
expérimenter autre chose
je ne sais pas qui a écrit le dossier de
presse on a très bien non c'est on
voulait essayer de voir si c'était
possible au cinéma d'apporter une
proposition un peu alternative aux
divertissements qui a d'habitude voire
c'était possible de rigoler autrement au
cinéma voilà c'est ce qu'on essaie en
cas de poids
a nommé anne saumâtre est bien briefé ya
eu alternative du divertissement
le film très originaux ce soir
effectivement vous voyez bien chers amis
téléspectateurs il ya d'abord un frimeur
préhistorique et ensuite du cinéma et
donc j'avais vraiment deux films très
très originaux très particulier et ça
nous montre la vigueur du cinéma
français
donc je me sens pas
le dieu de la blague donc il ya un an on
fait tirer des coups francs dans le bide
à faire ici c'est un vieillard c'est la
deuxième plus grosse frappe d'europe
après roberto carlos ça va à 210
kilomètres ça fait mal ça se voit ça
fait mal mais comme ça fait rigoler les
gens c'est pas un lancement il ya un
méli mauresmo a aussi qui vous sautent
des balles de service dans la c 180
kilomètres heure mais c'est plus ans et
puis aller mais où est le problème est
vraiment droit soit elle arrive est visé
le ballon se faisait piquer par des
guêpes elle arrive à la lecture de la
guêpe quels seront
alors le plus dur c'était quoi la
pesanteur la pesanteur on est allé le
plus dur pour la présenter c'est déjà
d'aller en russie je veux laisser un
cauchemar sur carla tout à l'heure avec
elena mais c'est un cauchemar ce pays on
bouffe mal on vous parle mal vous
traitent mal toute la journée n'ont pas
pas les noms auraient dû
rentrer dans la chambre pendant qu'on
dormait pour nous dire
que je vais arrêter les jours et des
étoiles c'était toujours amélie mauresmo
non mais le plus difficile a été la
centrifugeuse
structure c'est brad 18 mètres il peut
aller jusqu'à 30 g tu pèses 30 fois ton
corps mais là il ya que les cafards qui
résiste nous on est allé jusqu'à 6 g les
cosmonautes vont jusqu'à 8 oui mais le
problème c'est tout le sens se concentre
dans la tête donc et y avait eu bien
plus rien bah ouais tu vomis ouais t'as
pas le choix tout le monde vos mii mais
non rien à qui vomissent avec le sourire
moi j'aimerais vous versez en mai
vallouise alors vous êtes dans un avion
donc un iliouchine aurait fait à 15
mètres d'altitude d'un vol parabolique
et vous êtes en apesanteur ouais on est
les premiers français à l'avoir fait au
cinéma
pour la galère le truc c'est que c'est
qu'on était une trentaine dans
l'iliouchine il y avait vingt français
des russes les vins français étaient
tous malades on veut on vomit c'est
carrément dans des sacs poubelle ils
nous avaient donné des sacs poubelle
pour vomir dans les russes ils
soutiennent notre idée que
j'avais une formation avant une
formation est clairement quatre minutes
ils nous ont dit que peut-être à la fin
de la parabole les gaz de l'élu qui
n'arriveraient pas à redémarrer beaucoup
à ce moment là faudrait sauter en
parachute et sans traductrice quatre
minutes ils nous ont appris à sauter en
parachute je peux dire que quand le vol
comment ça
c'est utile parce que tu dis comment on
dit ah
y'a un moment aussi énorme vous êtes
stade gerland à lyon donc en face de la
tribune des bad gones ces sélectionnés
parmi les plus méchants de france avec
le kop de boulogne et certains ultras
mais on vous présente comme un groupe de
saint-etienne auxerre saint-etienne et
et lyon c'est à côté l'om et paris 6
mois la petite charrette et vous chanter
le vieux
lille perd son jeu de tête des
téléphones portables véridique et la
blague qu'on faisait ses on va revenir
l'année prochaine vous nous montrez les
chargeurs
[Musique]
faut pas creuser région at on créé une
faille spatio temporelle est aspiré
toutes les molécules de ton corps dans
une dimension parallèle
voici les 11 commandements de la blague
que vous aurez à accomplir pour remettre
les boeufs dans le droit chemin
de la rigolade
et n'oubliez pas maintenant en mission
pour dieu
rien de quoi vous avez touche
non
face aux chiffres othman bonjour
monsieur je suis fait mal de héros qui
s'est produit
je sais pas
quatre postes affectés au sabre ou capa
stade et tout ça vous dit
messieurs votre attention s'il vous
plaît j'ai dans la main une boîte de ce
médicament qu'on appelle médicaments
d'amour qui permet à tous les vieux de
se transformer en véritable aimant
encore toi maintenant
[Musique]
tout être humain servir de siège c'est
pourquoi je suis né m
très creek boys en loose et
trop de naïveté
je suis né
gagne donné la leçon au jeune
homme en tête tout seul c'était un bon
chercheur
qui sont là les autres années
m
à
on en a fait
bosser vos personnages ces faits
délictueux
on a travaillé à pizza
comme ça qu'on a bossé non dans la
sphère des saloperies et celle là c'est
de loin celle dont on est le plus fier
d'y avoir redonné c'est à bouira les
crottes de nez il faut que là ils sont
ici suis sur des flics
et c'est celui qui a le plus morfler oui
c'est lui qui a fait ça elle est
vraiment resté si longtemps garde à vue
pour l'ami doseur regarder parce que
c'est des matières fécales sur un flic
c'est vraiment un autre c'est considéré
comme matière michael vous tortiller
beaucoup du cul dans ce film turris tu
m'as dit que sa tête avait plus tard oui
moi je sais moi c'est pour ça que j'ai
remarqué que jean bart weyn stock
traquenard on retourne chez courbet
[Musique]
alors en hommage à mode qu on va faire
une interview au slip sur la tête bon
allez
celui dans la farine
chaque fois je saurai
jamais si ça va bien en ce moment il est
particulièrement stressée
mais qu'elle était du côté france d'en
bas attendons toujours moi ferons savoir
est-ce que c'est agréable à porter
pardon maman
pourquoi est ce que alain jean paul ils
en ont pas parce que vous avez des césar
césar
est ce que vous pensez michael que le
monde irait mieux si tout le monde avait
un type sur la tête je pense que le
monde irait mieux si les gens vais le
porter à l'envers comme une cascade de
john d'accord super s'avère compliqué
là-bas et émissions maintenant elle le
sera pas dans un autre
casser la gueule il faut éviter de me
poser des questions je suis capable de
donner du sens à mes réponses parce
qu'en ce moment j'ai l'impression
d'avoir une certaine sorte de fonctions
sociales
un peu je me la contrat vous gérez votre
film est très très libertaires très très
imprégnée de l'esprit on al'impression
un petit pansement quand même que c'est
l'apocalypse à télé il ya que des
émissions de classement comme s'il
fallait tout bien rangée avant que ce
soir mag aidons donc voila c'était un
petit peu histoire de dire merde comme
on est sûr service public on va faire
des questions qui peut plus intelligente
et pensez vous comme nietzsche que ce
qui ne vous tue pas vous rend plus fort
ça c'est kyo qu'il a dit
le groupe de rock qui
pensez-vous comme andré malraux que le
but d'une vie c'est de transformer son
expérience en conscience oui
mais bon on après l'interview est
vincent il a une
journaliste m'a demandé
s'il y avait un sens et vincent répondu
mon livre est l'autre nom
justement
on a même la dernière question la merde
quoi t'as pas ce sixième sens avec les
fringues
c'est à cause de
la
santé david vincent oui bon c'est vous
comme benjamin castaldi un pardon
enfin tous ces méchants quoi est il faut
taper 1 si tu veux
thiery sorte que ce soit fini par nous
résultat il fait toujours ici pourquoi
je sais plus pourquoi je suis venu
m pas
regardez un peu plus et noir at je suis
un peu embêté oui j'ai trouvé qu'on ait
baha surtout benjamin ah ouais ouais je
ne vais pas trouver assez présent dans
le gt mauvaise image te propose de
corriger une punition n'importe laquelle
quelle punition tu veux lui faire
michael je voudrais qu'ils nous chantent
du film bardé
de papier ouais à l'évasion de papier
je m'informe à la bar mitzvah du petit
david
quand je la regarde
moi l'homme est lourd coeur d'acier
deux ans à son corps de femme m je suis
un géant de papier
les bébés comme je la grèce mais que
j'ai pour les faits
si je suis en géant
mon pied ah ben ouais ouais
je suis en mode nuit longue mais la seml
pour vous michael un mail de l'ukba
retour et d'orléans nom de l'ue par
tours et d'orléans les on a quelqu'un
s'appelle comme ça est ce que vous
pensez michael quinze jours à venir vous
voir en vous disant que c'est terminé
tout ça qu'il faut font de l'argent
qu'il faut pas rester là c'était des
gens qui travaillent mais j'espère si ça
n'arrivait pas un jour ça va être ça
voudrait dire que tout ça n'a cessé
d'aller dans ce sens là voilà n'a aucun
sens exactement ce que je voulais dire
j'avais envie de citer vincent
merci
elle expliqué je ne
benjamin roure yens 2 pas nourri et oui
tout ça comment ça va
mais pas fier j'étais en qu'une maman
c'est rigolo lui ces et
maintenant
il
ouais c'est ça
ouais si et malines
[Musique]
soit parce
que les vaches étaient fâchés non
bonsoir je m'excuse d'avancé pour toutes
mes fautes en français jusqu à ce
qu
est ce que il a envie de voyager seul
l'impression qu'on peut plus
vous êtes clitoridienne
non non non on a dit pas au début ce
genre d'aidés régionales du coup on est
tous les deux d'accord on est tous
contents ils sont tous les deux premiers
tours
non non non non
non non quand je dis on est tous les
deux attendez mais continue elena nom
vient on se bat non non non non mais
attendez vous allez pas me laisser
s'échapper d'une fille à pipe
oyo
pire
m
comme ça c'est bon
[Musique]
voilà non madame rouge tout le monde se
donne aux halles et je crains une
nouvelle adresse à l économie la drees
bonsoir bonsoir tirer pourquoi pourquoi
elena lenina et pas elena staline a pour
l'instant ça se passe bien
parce que les mines en russe ça signifie
c'est lui qui appartient à elena et moi
je suis tellement en dépendantes dans ma
vie malheureusement que je pense que
j'appartiens que moi alors j'ai lu dans
france soir france soir du 6 mai 2006 à
six excuses à nous ils voient pas
derrière assez pour tout le monde ça
alors elena j'ai lu dans france soir du
6 mai 2003
une déclaration importante de vous vous
dites le baiser russe c'est sans la
langue
on baisse un peu la lumière on baisse un
petit peu la lumière voilà on me laisse
avec evanna alors c'est vrai que le
baiser russe et sans la langue c'est
vrai que les français ont énormément des
stéréotypes des fantasmes des russes des
clichés ça fait partie de ces
stéréotypes qui sont pas vrai que les
russes s'embrasse sur la bouche chaque
fois qu'il se voit en effet des virus
s'embrasse pas plus souvent sur la
bouche que les français n importe quel
avant
génie
m
[Musique]
voilà donc j'ai eu mon baiser russe
effectivement je veux dépasser sans la
langue c'est sans la langue c'est un
tube tu pousses tes lèvres toile élèves
de la fille mais non non ça serait bien
sûr les lèvres
moi tu ne filme pas alors on rejoue la
roma moi je suis ta phin ménard en plus
j'aime pas ta gueule ouverte alors bon
lna on est tous les deux on se pose
beaucoup de questions
c'est creux mentonnais
on se pose beaucoup de questions à votre
sujet
quel est votre véritable âge où tu me
fais peur
parce que parce que non je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que l'on ait ce clip
où l' on accepter les gens 19 à 29 ans
et on a dit l'ong à ce soir on est là
pour tordre le cou à toutes les rumeurs
on a dit que vous aviez plus que 29 ans
on avait dit pâtit c'est toi qui
craquent qui cadrait sur ton film ou pas
laurent
or actuellement dans la foule vous étiez
en vacances et donc vous avez moins de
29 ans il est là sinon vous n'auriez pas
été acceptée un high speed ball on est
d'accord
nature et alain
laurent on va te reprendre tout écart
est là alors on a dit bettini vedette de
télévision en russie vrai faux oui non
info ou intox j'ai une émission
hebdomadaire pour le vent majorettes et
cette émission mais je vais repasser
avec un autre projet à chaque semaine
l'euro c'est une émission hebdomadaire
pardon la traduction je ne me retrouve
plus
ses s'écrivait traduction là
bien
là
encore si nu celui-ci continue on
continue concentrez vous regardez moi on
a dit que dans l'aspi paul devient une
espèce de love affair avec doc gynéco
vrai coût non c'est parce qu'il agit lui
il a dit on a fait ce qu'on a voulu au
milieu de 50 caméras sont que les gens
s'en rendent compte ça c'est lequel sam
etiassé
imaginer c'est endemol a l'occasion me
montrer cette séquence ils ratent pas
ces pluies s'étaient pas gênés 2 en
avant c'est vrai loana alors on a dit
que vous étiez la maîtresse de vladimir
poutine vrai ou pas et du cuir à six
mois
non sérieusement non vous n'avez jamais
été la maîtresse de vladimir poutine je
ne sais pas est ce que malheureusement
heureusement non mais la dsi et la dsi
vous a interrogé là-dessus le
contre-espionnage français nous a
interrogés on m'interrogeait est-ce que
j'étais la représentante en france de
poutine mais pas est ce que je t'ai la
maîtresse bien on a dit que j'étais
végétarienne alors que je tiens j'ai
il y avait eu bat fils parce que j'étais
dessus je marque et ben ça s'appelle un
automate et
c'est quand même l'occasion des réseaux
on a dit que vous apparteniez à la mafia
russe
c'est pas vrai bien évidemment sinon je
pourrais dire que tous les allemands
c'est
là je pourrais dire que tous les
allemands sont masi tous les français
sans les
maladies on a dit que j'étais une
espionne du kgb que finalement dans nice
people avec tous les micros toutes les
caméras n'étiez pas gêné ça c'est vrai
avec vladimir poutine moi je comprends
plus rien oui non si j'ai bien compris
votre question est ce que ça m'a gêné ou
non la présence des caméras ça ne me
gêne pas parce que je suis depuis
longtemps l'habitude les caméras plomb
c'est parce que je l'espérais comme une
animatrice quand je travaille et que
l'on tente bien ce que c'est la guerre
soit 2 nécrophile maintenant
on indique qu à six mois après vous
auriez pu être la fiancée de paul loup
sulitzer je pense qu on est des gens des
différentes générations je ne sais pas
vous mais pas quand le mec est plus âgé
j'aime mais quand le mec est plus
intelligent
c'est dans le bouquin ils sont en plus
âgées
ena les mineurs zone il marre de tous
ces ragots de tous et en dit vous avez
décidé d'écrire un livre
autobiographique qui s'appelle cours
camarade cours chez michel lafon alors
vous racontez votre votre en france ans
en sibérie dans une ville qui s'appelle
à calais mme gauvreau doc
la cité des savants alors dans vos
parents était chercheur vite privilégiez
vous aviez quand même droit à tout ça ça
n'a rien à voir avec la politique ouais
c'est plutôt mes parents et l'endroit où
j'ai la chance de vivre cette cité des
savants des chaque voisin de palier et
et où le prix nobel de quelque chose au
l'académicien de quelque chose c'était
vraiment très impressionnant et très
utile à n'importe qui alors non mais
sérieusement c'est une éducation très
stricte que celle d'elena lénine à
regarder la télé interdite vous étiez
obligés de lire marx engels lénine pas
le droit de lire agatha christie ou du
maternelle montaigne seneca ou
chesterfield c'était quand même un peu
exagéré parce que
vous voyez
abattu c'est mon
fils ce sont les cigarettes en effet bon
sens
j'ai adoré alexandre dubois mais c'était
tombé par mes parents parce que c'était
une littérature que mon chien ming wang
pour les serres pour le cerveau et
laurent jouer un jour un jeu où vous
apprenez la cdc le choc c'est le choc
que là elle apprend qu'en france les
seuls que qui a c'est devant les cinémas
etc et supermarchés se sont plaints et
et vous découvrirez ce moment là
effectivement l'ampleur du mensonge
c'est à dire l'urss en fait avait créé
un un monde en carton-pâte un petit peu
comme les façades de deux de potemkine
quand l'impératrice passé vous
connaissez ça lna absolument je me
rappelle d'un de nos voisins non mais
démissionne de la physique nucléaire la
première fois qu'il a visitées pour un
congrès des savants
l'italie l'une des réunions en racontant
qu'il a pleuré le supermarché quand
c'était impressionnant quand gorbatchev
fait son discours où il annonce la fin
de l'urss votre mère pleure c'est pour
dire comme l'attachement de vos parents
à à l'union soviétique
il y avait plein de suicide parmi même
les agents de quai jobez ses horreurs
c'était une génération perdue les gens
arrêter toute leur vie pour les idéaux
de 2,2 t il
ils ont protégé leur pays et d'un coup
il n'y a rien pour quoi ils ont consacré
l'on sorte alors non mais il faut
souligner quand même et cela tant
boucher un coin mon garçon elena est
arrivé vierge au mariage mais
en tant qu on taquine je sais pas ce qu
on est acquis mais c'est beau moi je
trouve pourquoi c'est bien pourquoi il
quand vous rencontrez liège kenny vous
ne rêvez pas prononcer son prénom
vous découvrez qui a encore des classes
sociales en urss parce que finalement
vous vous êtes d'une classe privilégiée
évidemment vos parents les chercheurs
vous arrivez chez lui vous découvrez que
finalement les classes sociales n'ont
pas été abolie parce que ses parents ce
sont des ploucs un mon ex mari était
temps d enfant surdoué qui a ramassé
partout dans l'ex urss dans tout les
coins au le plus éloigné pour les mettre
tous dans l'académie baroque pour former
le logis de la nation de la nation dont
on a été aussi on faisait partie et
c'est vrai que ce genre de surdoué
bon ça dépend pas de classe ouais mais
quand vous tombez sur des parents alors
là c'est le choc vous dites bon alors
c'est le même choc quand je tombe dans
les français dans le pays france de la
france et quand je vois autant des
stéréotypes de pêcher des russes ça m'a
fait
l'effet des chocs dans l'autre sens on
revient de russie sont aussi des
stéréotypes sur les français inversement
les russes adorent la france pour les
russes c'est que les gens cultivés les
gens qui ont de la culture qui en qui on
a envie d'apprendre le français qui
adore la que la culture française la
littérature française je peux paraît
même que n'importe quel écolier russe si
vous le prenez il va vous citer beaucoup
plus des écrivains français que
peut-être un écolier france qu'il était
torturé se joue et non les russes
adorent
plein de choses en france votre cuisine
les fromages lepage la cosmétiques
décoratifs l'âme en tous cas merci
j'ai jamais entendu ce soit
c'est grâce à cette carte vous pouvez
revenir quand vous voulez l'ena même si
vous n'avez pas de promotion on pouvait
venir juste pour le plaisir pour dire
bonsoir
dont vous quittez yevgeny et vous
devenez mannequin à ce moment-là et
lennar 1 voilà il est alors
vous vous avez effectivement une danse
qu'est ce qui se passe j'ai fait tomber
mon stylo c'est un happening
je vais ramasser
[Applaudissements]
il est très très enfants alors d'écrire
à la télé de demain thierry en format
sera un moment de vérité avec laurent
boyer ça s'est passé sur la
margoulette elena thierry le goal et la
vie qu'est ce que tu fais moi ça
changeait quoi dire j'ai des tirs et je
crois que le moment de vérité
alors vous trouvez que les français
sérieusement sont un petit peu austère
ne sont pas très sexy en fait un oui
mais je trouve que les français sont
absolument sexy sauf que j'ai une chose
à reprocher enfin le françaises qui font
pas autant d efforts pour s'entretenir
mais je ne peux pas dire tout mais
[Applaudissements]
les françaises se coupe les ongles comme
des écolières qu'elle s'habille en noir
qu'elle met des chaussures plates
quelles sont pas sexy leur arrive
quelles sont infléchies vous dites mon
avis ils ont un peu moins enfin moins
sexy que c'est à dire ils font exprès
pour ne pas paraître le secret mais moi
je pensais toujours que centre
s'occuper de son nom c'est pas c'est pas
la bonne
on est né avec tout avec des même si
vous voulez avec mêmes bases mais pour
jean paul c'est vraiment sympa bon jour
de l'audience a fait les efforts non
certaines préfèrent ne pas porter détail
les talons haute non mais vous avez un
petit peu maison moi je suis assez
d'accord avec vous mais non excusez-moi
ne seraient tous et pas pour la ramener
mais on est allé en russie d'elena renom
n'a pas croisé à nous ne traductrice
le pt
cela m'a fait très plaisir elle s'enfuit
mairie
notre a dû donner envie de nous mettre
les deux doigts dans la bouche
ouais alors on continue donc vous
quittez yevgeny vous devenez mannequin
vous créez votre société de production
de télé après je vais vite chaud janvier
mission à toutes les chaînes hélas hélas
ce qui se passe c'est la lna et la d62
et la dalle et moi je suis buffalo grill
d'aller faire du skate non de changer de
sexe non pas alain et de nous mais de
loin pas le prononcer cosmétologie
figurative par téléphone jean paul c'est
pas d'aller d'aller en france non elle
décide de ne toucher qu'avec des hommes
riches et puissants
attendait mais c'est marc alexandre le
propriétaire de l'usiné nucléaire il a
quitté sa femme et sa maîtresse pourvu
de propriétaires du gène nucléaire il
avait dit ils avaient des datchas dans
la forêt cybervia s'est permis des
jacuzzis date qui avait dessiné arcade
mais j'avais des peintures mais j'ai
touché radioactifs en mairie non mais je
comprends la corée zidane dans cette
émission pour sa part bien au kung-fu
j'adore j'adore j'ai envie d'être chez
moi pour la regarder
elle
avec cendres à 6 e sont un seul crime
d'accueil il était riche mais
j'admire votre professionnalisme j'aime
beaucoup ma femme et lui si on met quoi
qu'est ce qui se passe et les non non
non je pense que tu manges lna c'est
marcel béliveau
son attaquant qui m'a appelé
pour me dire qu'on soit hier soir
c'est sûr mais s'ils ont pris un peu
l'accent canadien qu'elle a vu c'est
incroyable c'est sûr
mais c'est pas contre toi toi ton boulot
c'est devant signal on sait faire
chacun son job a autant de mal qu'un
code comique là c'est d'éloigner couché
avec du foie gras pour toi assez de
kicks et de
pas mal de la baie ont compris ça va
quand même mais oui c'est dommage parce
qu'elle allait saisir
la portée du foie gras et ont ils été
pourri pour me faire plaisir je veux
apporter du foie gras nord qui fait bien
de parler de ça parce qu'un jour j'ai
rencontré hélène sega dans le train et
elle était très elle disait ben oui à
chaque fois elle le prend très mal parce
qu'elle a l'impression qu'on se fout de
sa gueule de semaine mehdi lui parce que
quand je la croisais dans le train à
baho corps me pleurer même si tu le
coupé au montage mais fait un effort
pour la galerie convient à mon sens que
tu es sincère pour une fois hélène
j'étais dis très sincèrement
à l'oral ouais je te le dis très
sincèrement par le magazine que des
batteries mais je te le dis très
sincèrement h
30 au coach un petit peu je te le dis
très sincèrement de faire la gaule la
faconde et fanchone foot et la larme à
l'oeil bouge rien bouche par le clan
voit la beaujoire à nantes en fait trop
le vis très sincèrement l album
peut-être j'aime ton foie gras pourri
ça va déjà
message de charles aznavour qui veut
racheter les droits de la chance
j'ai parfois joué des mauvais tours
alors on continue elena dans la déconne
et moi ces mouvements sont rares et
surtout les dons sentons bien mais nous
ici je n'avais rien contre moi nous
demander comment traire mais jane
campion mois sur la bouche je préfère
que comment tu me met votre téléphone
ou mieux que tu m'embrasses car qui pue
de la gueule on peut lire
cette histoire depuis des années mais
attribue enfin on peut toujours rien
n'empêche que le bouquin raconte très
très bien la vie d'elena
obama essaie d'oublier
non
mes
amis
m
[Musique]
à
toi alors que s'excuser on est en fait
de rapport elle en a vu d'autres est ce
qu'on peut avoir levé et russe
et là bonjour vous avez vu dans le vote
ces brasiers tropicale je ne sais
combien dans les faits ce monsieur n'a
plus la mousse de lait fait son sac à
dos le chanteur s'est trompé
on va voir si elle est naïve capable de
s'acclimater en france elle est capable
harcèle ses chats climat terre en france
on va faire l'interview ce sondage
[Musique]
original
non là je vous demande de vous
concentrer un petit peu parce que je
vous demande de vous arrêter
c'est très intéressant c'est un test
donc je vais vous poser des questions et
on va voir si vous correspondez à la
moyenne des françaises on va voir si
vous êtes une française désormais alors
attention est ce que vous préférez faire
l'amour le matin au réveil ou le soir au
coucher le matin le soir le soir en
nocturne plutôt comme 69% des francaise
voila vous êtes
c'est
70% j'espère faire l'amour le soir avant
de s'endormir voilà voilà c'est votre
cas non moi j'ai fait l'amour au réveil
est gelée cassé
quelque 1 38 % des jeunes vous êtes
cassé alors là tu intéressant
faire l'amour elena dans le noir oui je
pense que c'est plutôt timide naz je
préfère d'accord comme 56% des français
soit la plaisir est là et tu ne devrais
française à texte intéressant est ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour faire l'amour où
il veut quand il veut où ils veulent
quand ils veulent
on va où il veut quand il veut je pense
pas comme les françaises bon 66 % des
françaises refusent de faire l'amour
quand j'ai vu beaucoup de cheveux
françaises sont des mythomanes way
34 qui sont d'accord pour faire l'amour
où il veut quand il comment ça se fait
qu'on tape tout le temps dans les 34
est ce que vous faites l'amour la
première fois le premier soir la
première rencontre tout de suite là ce
soir là après l'émission
j'ai pour moi l'amour c'est quelque
chose qui se passe dans la tête dans les
coeurs mais s'est pas
étendu cette amicale elle et elle est
comme la ja que douch % des françaises
qui baisent le premier soir on les amène
vous ouvrez française va me donner le
certificat de la naturalisation bien sûr
mais je vous donne tout fait tiens tu as
peu 39 % des françaises refusent la
fellation et vous le premier sera donc
m'expliquer qu'est ce que cela veut dire
la fellation alors je ne suis qu'une
étrange qu'elle sache dire cosmétiques
concupiscent
excusez moi
cette limite a appris le français à
l'âge de 5 ans à l'école maternelle en
sibérie augmentation de 5 ans déjà lui
il a promis
d'aller les pâtes les nations alain
chabat il fait trop froid s'abat
effectivement je suis assez d'accord
avec michael mais je vais tout de même
que voilà ces mots tu vois
ceci est une tête quelque part dans la
tête il y a une bouche je sais c'est
étonnant mais un oeil qu'on se repère
mais la conti opérer parce qu'on a
maintenant la
ccc barbecue c'est par vingt six ans
l'attendait attendait donc dosettes vous
êtes est ce que vous êtes comme 39% des
français vous refusez je vous adore je
préfère cunnilingus
rien à dire
alors on attend qu'une whip it nom
71 % des françaises seraient choqués si
un couple d'amis leur proposer d'aller
dans un club échangiste mais je
comprends ouais c'est pas des vrais amis
dans ce cas il faudra qu'on discute
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le en
fidélité
complexe les instituts travail sur cette
problème je pense pas qu'on va trouver
la solution par les intellectuels tu
leur demandes est ce que tu te couches
et répondent les instituts
et horrifié c'est la cité des savants
oui enfin alors dernière question êtes
vous prête à devenir l'esclave sexuelle
de votre mec là maintenant
j'ai le chiffre des françaises c'est pas
beaucoup il faut dire je pense que c'est
possible qu'une femme tombe tellement
amoureuse d'un des noms qu'elle devient
dépendante de lui dans le domaine sexuel
absolument mais je pense que je dis non
parce c'est formidable mais de l'autre
parent c'est comme tout les genres de
dépendance c'est quand même très
difficile à vivre
vachement bien mais oui mais c'est sa
question est là non mais tu lui poses
des questions que l intellectuel jeu
m
et
sur mission
au sous sol
[Musique]
j'accueille ma tante chanel bouras
m
bon michael on va parler de choses
sérieuses là on va parler du voile
d'accord et ben ali
gel
non c'est pour les gens qui vous donnera
un élan poste
m
et partout le bon sens tout à l'heure
j'ai enfin
vous avez un coiffeur fesses à une
coiffeuse toiletteur peiné
mais en vous dirai pas ce que mireille
tutu s'est embrassés à la russe non j'ai
pas bien compris les est satisfait des
premiers soirs nom des trucs
à toi et ton mari d'aller dans un club
échangiste cuir et mireille parle-nous
d'alexandre un peu ce milliardaire russe
qui avait beaucoup d'un tiers dans la
forêt sibérienne c'est parce qu'il ya eu
mais c'est pas ce film c'est anormal
chrome est le champion
rémy
mireille bas va s'imposer dans cette
élection comme une mascotte ne pourra
donc jamais le noise vous étiez samedi
dernier à la manif contre la loi sur le
voile à l'école car vous êtes contre il
faut bien le dire vous dit si on exclut
ces jeunes filles voilées de l'école
laïque elles vont devenir encore moins
laïque est effectivement sur les
renvoyer chez elles elles vont être
encore plus musulmane disons je crois
que il faut laisser la liberté à chacun
il ya qu'en france en ce moment où on
pose toutes ces questions moi qui ai
l'habitude de voyager par le sport ou
par autres j'entends et a qu'en france
où j'entends ces choses là maintenant
aussi j'aimerais expliquer aux gens que
j'ai participé à cette manifestion cette
manifestation en tant qu'individu
la société civile parce que je suis
quand j'entends des choses qui me
choquent charger un peu militant depuis
que je suis enfant et quand il ya des
choses qui me choquent la preuve enfin
quand il ya eu le pen qui est passé
souvent tout rond c'est de manifester
parce qu'il y avait un acteur une
personne raciste qu'elle est passée
enfin bref l'essentiel ce sera sans
accroc
nouvelle d'accord mais tu ne parles pas
de journal pour moi la chose la plus
importante c'est le savoir et la
connaissance donc à partir du moment où
tu enlèves les gens l'école c'est à dire
que même si on est dans l'erreur ouais
tu vas l'école était dans l'erreur bon
ton cas vous allez et ses toits des
colts par an sur intégrisme je ne sais
pas tu vas l'école mais s'ils ont pu
sont enlève de ça on t'enlève l'école
pour pouvoir tout mélanger et échanger
avec des ouf comme cela enfin de partout
tu peux tu ouvres ir ou à prendre ben tu
vas tu vas donc je vois pas où c'est que
tu peux tu vas devenir encore plus
renfermés sur toi-même exactement
fondamentale pour moi la chose la plus
importante c'est de l'accès au savoir et
le savoir il a connaissance alors
vous dites que finalement le port du
voile peut effectivement peut-être
perturber la scolarité mais moins qu'un
string qui dépasse d'un jean
non je plaisante est pas ce que j'ai
entendu des gamins diabaté à la télé et
ça m'avait fait rire qui disait que un
peu comme dans son style disait qu'ils
étaient venus des rangs dérangé par un
string quand il était à l'école qui
dépassait du jeans que par un foulard
l'afrique le foulard personnes à calcul
alors que la fille quand en classe et un
bon pull et tels actes se sen t +
déconcentrer car ça que par le truc cool
mais vous savez que vous êtes
vous êtes contre le port du string à
l'école non moi je suis pas pour moi
chacun fait ce qui m'inquiète pour le
port des deux en même temps
djamel vous vous jugé que cette loi
qu'ils hainaut fob imbécile et raciste
et blitz gouvernement est en train
d'installer l'islamophobie dans ce pays
la preuve hier ils ont commencé à dire
que la barbe il fallait pas la barbe
fine et le bandana qu'elle bandana non
mais deviennent de plus en plus dit oh
la la
alors j'ai dit à cette manifestation
donc samedi le problème c'est que
d'abord c'est bon pour le pen c'est à
dire que quand les français voient au
journal télévisé tous et tous ces gens
qui cherchent ils vous pensez bien que
ça va faire des voix en plus pour le pen
selon un effet station vous le savez
très bien et l'autre problème c'est
aussi que beaucoup de députés de droite
à commencer par balladur qui étaient
d'accord pour ne pas voter la loi il
disait finalement oui cette fois ça sert
à rien depuis la manifestation de sa
mise en changer d'avis son envie de la
beauté je vous pensais pas que ce genre
de manifestation
à quelques mois des élections peut
finalement de provoquer un raidissement
de la classe politique française moi je
pense oui ouais ouais je pense moi je
pense que vous verrez la manif je pense
que le grand gagnant pas de la manif
parce que ya pas que ça fait ça fait
quelques temps quand même que
l'événement ouais que couvre les médias
quoi donc c'est pas une question de
manifs ou pas de manif ça depuis très
longtemps on en parle
maintenant je pense que cette politique
la mènera
alors je crois que c'est pas bon à cette
manifestation il y avait aussi mohamed
latrèche du pmf le parti des musulmans
de france alors lui les antisionistes
bon ça c'est son droit il est aussi
terriblement antisémite il est l'éditeur
du manifeste judéo nazis d'ariel sharon
qui est une vraie fausse interview du
premier ministre d'israël il était à la
tribune avec serge thion qui était un
négationniste très connu et il a dit en
parlant de serge thion je suis très
content et fier de le connaître est ce
que à un moment finalement même si vous
n'étiez pas derrière lui on a bien
compris mais est ce qu'à un moment le
fait finalement de manifester avec
quelqu'un comme la trèche c'est pas
dangereux maintenant mais moi comme je
dis c'est un ami sic au début qui est
venu dans mon salon de thé et qu'ils me
diront manifestent samedi jeudi pour 7
contre cette loi je dis bah écoute c'est
super moi aussi je suis contre cette loi
là et après dans les médias j'entendais
tous les jours comme quoi il y avait une
espèce de groupe enfin participer mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc là
personne ne le connaît on ne connaît
même pas et non je suis allé en tant
qu'observateur pour montrer que j'étais
contre 7 là mais jamais dit je suis
d'aucune mouvance vous l'avez déclaré
intéressé planifie quand j'ai entendu
parler
cette personne veut se sauver ouais
ouais ouais mais c'est vrai qu'à cette
manif on aurait préféré voir monseigneur
lustiger hologram industries mais moi ça
j'ai cru qu'il avait ça moi j'ai cru
qu'ils avaient tout le monde quoi c'est
quand même une loi raciste quoi vous
savez quand même que vous êtes en train
de devenir le porte parole des musulmans
il faudra bien dans tous les pays du
monde il ya des gens qui sont un moment
porté porté sur le 2 ans et jean les des
gens qui n'osent pas parler et moi ça va
chier quoi y'a des gens qui pensent qu'à
leur business tu vois alors que un
moment donné on se fait insulter tout le
temps j'ai ramené un petit manifeste ici
tous les jours tu vois on est quand même
des musulmans chacun a sa digne à sa
dignité tu vas rien sur et puis un
programme qui dit va qui rata dignité en
enfer s'il le faut et refuse de
médiation même au paradis ouais et de
moutanabi ça et quand tu entends un mec
comme claude imbert clown amer qui dit
je suis un peu islamophobe
ça ne me gêne pas de le dire j'ai le
droit de penser que l'islam je dis bien
l'islam je ne parle même pas des
islamistes apporte une certaine timidité
qui en effet me rends islamophobe et ça
c'est un bear qu'entend quand tu entends
matérialiste au journal le point le
point web et soeurs quand tu entends
houellebecq qui dit la religion à
houellebecq la religion la plus con
c'est quand même l'islam quand on lit le
coran en effondré il faut admettre une
chose dont je veux dire moi je suis
catholique mais en même temps en france
de tous temps il ya des gens confié sur
la religion catholique et on a appris à
vivre avec ça fait partie de la
démocratie ça non ouais ça fait partie
de la vie on échoue dessus mais je veux
dire quand je vois le pain aux guignols
qui prend de la coke par exemple ça me
gêne mais voilà c'est comme ça ils ont
le droit de le faire mais je dis pas
qu'on n'a pas droit de le faire mais de
dire des conneries concerne un ministre
quand il est commis qui plaisantent
là-dessus encore compréhensible mais
quand c'est un ministre qui dit xavier
darcos qui dit content quand on n'aime
pas la république française on va
ailleurs à la france aimez là ou quittez
là
c'est à dire que quand t'es pas content
se permettre ce que c'est toi mais ce
qui s'est passé que ses chansons
françaises le problème c'est qu'on
n'accepte pas la preuve
la preuve c'est que comment un ministre
le ministre le premier ministre de
l'intérieur
sarkozy qui soi-disant parle de
république wael nicolas decamps lutter
contre la loi et finalement il s'est
rallié
s'il va demander ça veut dire qu'il va
demander son avis à l'étranger c'est à
dire qu'il arriva il va en egypte pour
demander à soi disant cherchons un
savant religieux pour le dire est ce que
j'ai le droit quand même de faire ça ça
veut dire qu il alors que c'est un
problème franco français est assez bien
en tous les cas de prendre la vie des
des sommités musulmanes dans le monde
mais ce soutien de muter on ne connaît
pas à pas de sommités c'est à dire ça
nous on en sait un problème franco
français je vois pas pourquoi ça veut
dire qu'ils n'acceptent pas encore
comprend on n'est pas que comme français
en france c'est ça le problème mais il
ya un autre truc important s'il te plait
je devrais te dire c'est moi j'ai fait
les jeux olympiques tu vas j'ai rapporté
des médailles pour la france et pour il
ya des valeurs que j'ai représenté mais
ces valeurs là quand j'ai lu cet article
à cette déclaration c'est ça que j'ai
défendue tu vois alors j'aimerais
j'aimerais vous lire cette déclaration
qui dit tout déclaration ne quitte
jamais des garçons des droits universels
des droits de l'homme masi chez claire
c'est à dire que même les lois qu'on
fait les déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme c'est au dessus c'est
vrai d'accord donc il faut bien écouter
je ne la porte l'attention de nos gens
tu vas le mien écouter cette déclaration
qui dit que toute personne a droit à la
liberté de pensée de conscience et de
religion ce droit implique la liberté de
manifester sa religion ou sa conviction
seule ou en commun tant en public qu'en
privé par l'aise par l'enseignement les
pratiques le culte et l'accomplissement
des rites
c'est clair non donc je ne sais pas ce
qu'on essaie en fait ça c'est l'arbre
qui cache la forêt la france a beaucoup
de problèmes en ce moment niveau chômage
très haut niveau il ya trente minutes
donc dans les sociétés ya un moment il
ya plein de problèmes sauf qu'on met sur
l'histoire du voile ça va à cacher tous
les problèmes qu'on a c'est un peu comme
tu pensé un peu concédé six coups sûrs
de roland dumas sur l' affaire des
frégates de taïwan coneway je croyais
pas bien son histoire
voiture en corrélation non mais bon tu
va donc continuer à manifester pour
tulle a mieux fait que je continue à
dire ma vérité tout le temps mais
maintenant on va essayer de ne pas se
faire piéger par certains mais c'est
clair que non parce que si c'est si ça
avait été les juifs qui veut la paix les
kings djamel on va enlever nos trucs je
vais avec eux mais manifestèrent bien
merci djamel on a parlé du voile mais
cette loi met en cause une autre
catégorie de la population française ce
sont les sikhs voici man preet singh
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue même preet singh dans
tout le monde en parle des émissions où
tout le monde par la preuve bonsoir donc
il ya 7000 sic en france surtout des
gens qui sont des réfugiés victimes de
la répression dont les cycles sont
victimes en inde et puisque les sikhs
veulent l'indépendance du calice temps
donc effectivement ça pose des problèmes
avec avec l'inde alors le cyclisme
qu'est ce que le cyclisme c'est une des
quatre grandes religions de l'inde ainsi
nos religions monothéistes qui rejette
toutes les pratiques hindous croyance
des classes dans plusieurs dieux les
castes la crémation des veuves le
mariage des enfants la claustration des
femmes etc donc c'est une religion 10
hakim roule oui c'est une agent beaucoup
beaucoup plus cool
donc les idéaux des cycles sont assez
simple c'est méditer travailler et
partage et voilà c'est vraiment la
morale de votre religion les femmes sont
les égales des hommes dans le cyclisme
il n'y a pas de supériorité pas de tabac
pas d'alcool un petit peu comme dans la
religion musulmane on est alors les six
que ne se coupe pas les cheveux ni la
barbe sans respect sans respect de la
nature on est sur terre on a on a eu la
barbe on a eu les cheveux on ne va pas
donner une paire de ciseaux avec un donc
la base de la religion et qu'on protège
voilà on regarde ce que nous a donné la
nature ou les femmes chez vous portent
la même chose porte la même chose nous
jouerons aussi les hommes et les femmes
portent sur ben voilà et donc
effectivement ce turban vous refusé de
l'enlever pour vous cette loi est
absolument inacceptable et d'ailleurs
fait une lettre à jacques chirac en
disant que le turban n'est pas chez vous
un signe de fondamentalisme ou
d'intégrisme alors évidemment après on
cherche des solutions lors luc ferry qui
a toujours de bonnes idées qui a trouvé
l'idée du bandana de la barre dans
chaque cas des vraies idées lui l'a
proposé ce qu'il appelle le turban
invisible luc ferry a inventé le turban
invisible c'est à dire c'est à toi c'est
juste c'est un fils et un ca petit filet
que vous mettriez ce que je veux c'est
ridicule pour aller à l'école mais vous
auriez un petit filet qu'on ne verrait
pas qu'ils tiendraient vos cheveux enfin
on est vraiment en même temps on est
dans le bonheur c'est pour montrer qu'en
de paris est la capitale de la mode
donc luc ferry ce qu'il aimerait si vous
ayez un fil invisible et que vous radier
votre barbe puisque maintenant d'après
ce qu'ils disent la barbe est aussi un
signe ainsi d'intégrer ce pour assurer
luc ferry le raser sa barbe avec le
rasoir invisible
bon à savoir quand même pour les
politiques c'est que le turban vous dit
c'est pas comme une croix cc clôture
m'en fait partie de notre corps sans
turban on n'est plus des sikhs c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très de très
très importante ne s'est pas juste
décoratifs et ses amis fichés chez les
ch et les cycles le turban gars c'est
parce qu'il faut pas se couper les
cheveux parce que dieu voulait cacher
voilà c'est pour les cacher on les cache
pas on les protège voilà d'accord c'est
une sorte en 1 de la personne qui porte
le turban est une personne respectée
donc notre nom mot de base de lait base
de la religion et qu'on respecte toutes
les religions et tous les toutes les
personnes qu'il ya dans le monde que ce
soit des personnes qui sont croyants ou
non croyants
donc c'est un signe de respect kaunas un
signe de dignité donc touché où on faire
enlever le turban dans le monde entier
est une sorte d' insulte alors vous
dites sans turban donc on n'est plus des
cycles oui c'est un truc sacré le turban
c'est pas comme un chapeau ou une
casquette quoi c'est vraiment incroyable
moi je me porte 24 heures sur 24 devant
vous dormez avec je dors avec je
l'enlève juste pour me laver les cheveux
ou pour payer mes cheveux donc et il
n'est pas loin de moi il reste à côté de
moi et je leur porte directeur chirac
jacques chirac a besoin d'un public a
dit la laïcité n'est pas négociable et
vous vous dites notre foi non plus voilà
vous donnons écossais a besoin
négociable et vous dit que finalement ça
s'est vu ce gars là c'est grave en tous
les cas pas ce que vous dites que si
vous étiez obligés d'enlever votre
turban pour aller à l'école vous
arrêteriez d'aller à l'école
vous personnellement et là on rejoint ce
que disait djamel bouras tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que donc en interdisant aux
gens l'accès à l'école publique
finalement les renferme dans leur ghetto
donc c'est une ghettoïsation finalement
laura droit communautarisme
faire de l'anti communautarisme on y va
à droite directement là on est là on
ensemble les communautés son ensemble je
connais beaucoup de personnes d'autres
communautés on a grandi ensemble ben on
arrivé à ce point là c'est sûr que si on
fait des écoles séparées on on se casse
entre nous laisse rien entre nous c'est
quelque chose d'inadmissible quoi ils
viennent pour l'école publique en fait
pour les collègues moi pour l'instant je
on a pas de problème nous classique en
majorité nous n'avons pas de problèmes à
l'école nous portons nos turban à
l'école est une sorte de tolérance mais
on a peur pour la suite que cette loi
soit votée l'année prochaine la salle
mozart de vos problèmes sauf là où ça
peut gêner peut-être si un élève
derrière voit moins bien si on s'active
et peut-être de s'organiser non
alors il ya un problème par exemple
souvent les musulmans intégristes
ça commence par le voile puis après ils
disent on veut plus participer aux cours
de gym on va plus participer aux cours
de biologie on va plus participer aux
cours d'histoire géo donc ça commence à
poser des problèmes effectivement bon
vous vous acceptez les cours d'histoire
géo la gym la biologie oui n'oubliez pas
de problème à ce genre de refus en plus
notre fille derrière quoi il derrière 24
ans qu'à chaque établissement est
généralisée des établissements chaque
appartement j'ai entendu ces histoires
et puis après c'est le docteur qui a
fait un certificat après s'être problème
est que le docteur certificat tu vois
c'est pas de lag on va faire une loi
pour interdire ce qu'ils veulent
vraiment le maître parce que c'est leur
conviction etc on va pas rentrer dans
leurs pensées d'en haut dans leur
intérieur
c'est ce qui se passait avant et c'était
pas bien ça apparemment non puisque il
faut une loi alain me permettre match
est un peu david tout le monde
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
témoigner et à bientôt on suivra ce qui
se passera pour les sites vous savez que
vous savez qu'à tout le monde en parle
on a été les premiers c'est incroyable
tout mandat car il s'est invité en
tchétchène c'est qu'elle n'ait jamais eu
de titre chaîne la télévision jusqu'à ce
qu'on la vie intérieure nés les premiers
invités ainsi qu et on vous remercie
beaucoup d'aidé
[Musique]
ouais
je voudrais tout lieu te plaît
normand jardin
voici benjamin biolay
soit
ça m'a donné bonsoir alors m'avait dit
une fois benjamin je vous ai une
interview technicolor vous avez dit ce
qui peut me rendre rouge de honte c'est
d'être mal coiffée et qu'on me fasse des
réflexions sur ma coiffure alors qu'ici
elle qui s'y colle
pourquoi vous mettez pas à turban
benjamin c'est pas la bonne éducation et
je vais
bien benjamin ça va ça va je fais un
compliment vous êtes le wonderboy de la
pop française
et depuis l'es2 puis salvador tout le
monde veut bosser avec vous souvent des
gens âgés d'ailleurs juliette gréco
valérie lagrange françoise hardy il faut
dire aussi qu'ils aillent vers nova et
nadia seraient donc finalement ça
équilibre alors faut dire
qu'effectivement vous êtes très doué il
est doué ce garçon déçu que se disent
malgré une enfance assez modeste avec un
père agent de maîtrise à la mnef et une
mère femme au foyer vous grandissez dans
un hlm mais vous avez une éducation
culturelle qui est très bourgeoise juin
bizarrement
la bourgeoisie en fête de la famille de
mon père voilà alors vous êtes au violon
à cinq ans mais pourquoi ils avaient
acheté des chaussures art aujourd'hui ma
fille
il est au violon à cinq ans et puis
alors après donc c'est bien violent
parce que dans le chai les gens modestes
si tu veux le 11 bat du violon anjou du
des cuivres ont en général
des pauvres ou d'un tronc
des casseroles bien sûr balle est passée
de moins cher sais tu sais pas ce n'est
pas facebook
d'un qu'au début il est dans le violon
ce qui est assez étonnant compte tenu de
ses origines monsieur et après il ya le
tubiste qui meurt et vous vous retrouvez
à là c'est terrible en train de jouer du
tuba à l'e10 est très pénible et dual
c'est très pénible parce que par exemple
dans un orchestre ont joué une note
toutes les 20 minutes qu'il ya des fois
non mais c'est pas ça s'est également vu
une équipe de former les mets qu'ils
écoutent la radio 1 j'écoute le
multiplex avec eugène saccomano
s'écouter jeunes sur la neige gelée mais
quand tu vois ce que tu sais pas c'est
quand tu vois nos normes hors caisse
comme ça il ya un mois
alors donc comme je les dis enfance
musical vous avez l'oreille absolue je
les salue mais tant mieux pour vous
parce que vous trouviez ça pénible s'est
quant à elle l'oreille absolue alors là
je salut tu entends je vous en lui il
avait vingt sur vingt en dictée
mélodique cirque l'oreille absolue
entente où tu entends toutes les
de nature un très violent au cinquième
rang tu l'entends c'est quand j'ai dit
est ce que vous avez entendu une semaine
et
de changer la classe
au nord-ouest écoute ça ouais tiens
qu'est né ce genre de site attendait ici
et pourrait peser sur l'oreille absolue
alors tu as par chance c'est une fête ce
que m'a expliqué ça m intéresse et
michael parce que je l'aurais que barnes
et quel état on en a marre d'être à côté
de laurent d'ombré qui fait le succès
mikel michael l'oreille absolue tu
entends toutes les notes et alors il ya
un autre truc que je savais pas c'est
l'oreille harmonique et j'arrive face
alors heureuse
gentil harrison avait l'oreille
harmonique c'est à dire que george
harrison il fait partie des gens qui
entendent tous les accords c'est
formidable c'est le daily nk stone qui
avait sept capes c'est ça que voudriez
l'oreille harmonix est votre rêve en
fait c'est moi vous avez un peu non
en plus c'est votre travail pour les
autres vous devez écouter non en plus de
votre travail pour les autres vous
faites vos albums et là une influence
majeure c'est mélodie nelson chaque
banque vous étiez petit vous aviez
entendu ce concept album de serge
gainsbourg j'aimerais beaucoup influencé
des roses est sorti un premier album qui
s'appelle enfin double qui s'appelait
rose kennedy 1 qui était consacrée à la
famille à la famille kennedy d'umbro est
rarement très romancé et aujourd'hui
vous sorti donc négatif qui est un
double cd le single en promo s'appelle
je ne t'ai pas aimé
le son
[Musique]
je
je vais
jusque tôt toute l'année
sous des rangs
j'étais
je suis
ils sont
c'est tout
shu
je creuse
[Musique]
benjamin mallet je n'ai pas aimé extrait
de son nouvel album qui s'appelle mais
gatti en duo avec carat
mastroianni on avait déjà entendu
d'ailleurs dans un album de doc gynéco
qui s'appelle quality street et la
chanson s'appelait trop jeune policier
doc gynéco j'ai entendu parler d'accord
vu aussi oui alors je vais écrire des
chansons pour votre époux de chiara
mastroianni mais je pense soin de lui
faire un petit album un petit sympa
alors vous dites quand vous parlez de
votre couple avec chiara mastroianni
on n'est pas un couple public le seul
truc c'est assez drôle c'est le truc on
est ensemble c'est le mariage c'est vrai
c'est vrai d'ailleurs là vous êtes sans
elle ce soir absolument c'est sûr sur ce
que c'est dans la loge en a fait venir
ses valeurs
alors commandant les belles-mères
catherine justement elle va très bien
elle va très bien est-ce que vous
déjeuner chez elle le dimanche à midi ça
peut arriver et des paupières qu'on m'a
dit ça vous arrive mais des fois vous
trouvez des excuses pour pas y aller à
ce déjeuner du dimanche non non vous y
allez ouais ça vous plaît d'y aller
bouffer chez votre belle d'âge ça vous
plaît ouais comme j'en gardais drucker
en semble absolument vous y avez offert
quoi pendrel je sais plus et vous en
verrez plus elle vous a offert quoi ta
fille c'est pas mal
un cendrier en forme de concours
ça lui plaît catherine deneuve d'être
grand mère ouais mais beaucoup oui c'est
marrant ça je me dis sans vous aimeriez
que chiara mastroianni sa fille lui
ressemble
si ça arrive je
dis rien je pose des questions moi et ça
ou gloria lasso faut choisir
ce canal est ce que vous l'avez du nu
dans belle de jour catherine deneuve est
belle de jour 1 quelque
20% des français tu feras un plan à
trois examens
la réplication est quelque peu
prétentieux ah oui alors on m'a dit non
non on n'est pas content il va chez
catherine on m'a dit un sur le parquet
sa séance avait lieu ce schisme
[Musique]
une partie des vacances c'est quoi ce
alors si les vacances c'est le thème
comme on en prend à peine de partir à la
neige
paulo
et puis apple ios on s'endort 9
la monogamie quand on aime les chiffres
il put mener
on peut l'être
tous les
[Musique]
jeux et comme le patron vous des dépôts
en espèces
navarro chirac
voilà
à vue ils sont par hull où mes potes
elle sent super tes posts et un forfait
c'est
satan brunet donc grâce à un jeu où il
faut laisser chaque laiterie
suis encore plus que tout oui donc vrai
alors benjamin jama violées donc vous
avez la réputation d'être un petit peu
un petit peu snob comme ça un petit peu
prétentieux parce que j'ai un peu timide
et je fais pas les chansons très
amusante n'est ce pas une attitude que
vous avez aussi un petit peu comme ça je
sais pas si pièces de votre côté émotif
qui vous rend un peu distant on a
l'impression vous méprisez un peu les
gens c'est vrai nom si je prends des
médicaments avant les émissions d'abord
revanche pas on se dit il avec la fille
de donna avec ma fille de mastroianni ça
a marché maintenant donc non il
ya un autre truc qui courent sur vous
aussi je préfère qu'on en parle
clairement benjamin
rendez vous avez une carte du parti
socialiste j'avais jamais je ne voulais
plus c'est toi c'est moi
je vous l'avais gardé la carte permet
collector les plasma qui on peut pas la
déchire vous l'avez garder non bien sûr
j'ai vite comme un peu snob parce que
vous allez écrire un roman comme par
hasard c'est l'année rêve quand même pas
vraiment j'adorerais mais c'est pas du
tout abattement donc finalement vous
êtes sympas ils faire sympa bien alors
vous êtes vous êtes un excellent
ensemble writer vous écrivez les paroles
j'écrivais les musiques donc on va vous
faire une interview à quoi ça rime
[Musique]
benjamin biolay si je vous demande de
faire une vie mme sur sarkozy
ça suffit
je n'ose pas sa fille revient revient
jeu star robert hollande trop loin pour
moi est la volonté les autres pays du
fromage quoi
payer du tout si une prime sur chirac
arnaque alia voilà une rime sur kara
tu as droit l'italien
grimshaw deneuve sa vie son oeuvre enfin
anna votre petite fille à papa papa
salvador
couilles en or du
queens à la plus grande fan
bénabar couillon pourquoi c'est bonnard
vincent delerm en bons termes
laurent baffie
[Musique]
j'aime bien son côté zoologue
technologie est mature passionnés
zoophilie en main de
thierry ardisson
c'est le patron
elle benjamin biolay
j'appelle les gars
le cv
[Musique]
est-ce que mal et hip hop venir pour me
mais pousse t un petit peu avant
l'interview
[Musique]
pour la génération
pour
je
[Musique]
samar jeu
et
[Musique]
et maintenant je vante d'être un petit
peu concentré on accueille quelqu'un qui
a écrit un livre bouleversant réellement
bouleversant j'accueille christophe
tison
[Musique]
christophe tison bonsoir si souvent
djamel bouras elena lenina benjamin
biolay jean paul rouve michaël youn
alain chabat laurent baffie physique
vote libre et est bouleversant c'est
vrai que ça faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas lu un truc aussi aussi fort
ça s'appelle il m'aimait essai publié
chez grasset alors d'abord on va dire
qui vous êtes vous avait 42 ans vous
êtes rédac chef au service culture à
canal+ et haï télévision et vous avez
déjà publié deux bouquins la drogue
expliquer aux parents chez balland
périence oui
nos enfants fr heller dû vite toujours
chez balland mais alors on revient il
m'aimait il c'est un adulte qui était
amoureux de l'enfant que vous étiez et
le livre raconte comment son amour parce
que c'était de l'amour comment son amour
vous a détruit oui oui c'est vrai alors
comme le fait remarquer notre ami
frédéric beigbeder dans voici d'habitude
la littérature abordé le sujet de la de
la pédophilie par l'angle du narrateur
pédophile c'est nabokov dans le lit
cassé rose bonbon c'est il entrerait
dans la légende et en général quand
c'est des victimes qui témoigne c'est
plutôt des témoignages assez moureaux
assez vertueux est là pour la première
fois c'est toujours beigbeder qui parle
il dit il on ose dire oui les enfants
sont attirés par les adultes ils aiment
qu'on les cajole voilà finalement le
scad de très nouveau et à la fois de
très de très choquant mais de très vrai
dans votre livre c'est qu'en fait
l'enfant que vous étiez
aimé je dirai pas son bourreau enfin
aimer son amant d'une certaine façon il
était attiré par lui si oui c'est un peu
ça c'est un peu le syndrome de stockholm
où c'est
c'est
quand un adulte prends soin de toi
finalement tulle m quoi il ya un truc un
truc très fort ouais il remplace ton
père est en place la mer et puis et puis
finalement ben tu tu ne peux m empêcher
de l'aimer jusqu'au moment où vient le
soir mais on se retrouve dans le lit
avec lui ou là c'est horrible ouais
alors vous dit j'aurais dû refuser d'y
aller et pourtant c'est bien moi qui
retourner le voir c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il vous embrasse et ils
vous cajoler il vous prodiguer de
l'amour il s'intéressait à vous et vous
étiez d'une certaine façon en tiré par
lui pour dire les choses crûment bah oui
il avait une énorme
énorme sexe et puis moi j'étais tout
petit j'ai eu moi j'ai une fille qui a 9
ans ça a commencé quand j'avais 9 ans je
me dis mais qu'est ce que ces petits
quoi c'est hallucinant et et this et je
n'arrive pas je n'arrive pas à m'y faire
et bon finalement c'est vrai que c'est
vrai qu'il m'est même que je lai
et finalement il me faisait mal ouais
j'ai bien dans le livre c'est vraiment
très étonnant et très choquant moi j'ai
eu vraiment du mal car j'ai du mal à
lire à lille mais là vraiment c'est très
fort ce qui était risqué terry dans le
bouquin c'est cette ambivalence est à
dire que celui qui vous fait le plus de
mal est également celui qui vous fait le
plus de bien une certaine façon ouais
c'est vrai nom c'est vrai c'est vrai que
c'était un type génial parce que je vais
pas faire maintenant je vais pas faire
son apologie aujourd'hui mais c'était
quand même un type génial parce que il
me faisait lire il faisait il faisait
lire boris vian il faisait lire sartre
etc
des lectures que j'aurais jamais eu si
j'avais été sans lui il me projetait des
films j'allais dans des cinémas de remy
vous emmener
pas omis le décaméron il me projetais il
me projetais caisse il me projetais
d'aider tout tout tout les lauzes et et
il était incroyable avec moi vraiment il
était incroyable de d'amour de tendresse
de bon et le problème c'est que après je
le paye est quoi ouais et billie jean
mais j'y pense fortement j'avais à
chaque fois que joue à michael jackson
j'y pense c'est sûr il faut dire à nos
amis téléspectateurs que cette histoire
se passe quand même aux pires moments de
l'époque baba cool post-soixante-huitard
d'accès l'époque la sexualité n'a pas de
règles piles et les drogues partout sur
votre mère fumer des pétards devant vous
c'était l'époque de la permissivité une
époque assez libertaire naturiste les
enfants sont livrés à eux-mêmes donc
ouais mais c'était en même temps c'était
une époque génial c'était absolument
génial moi j'adorais je me trouvais dans
une petite ville dans une espèce de
traction avant vert pomme et cetera avec
des mecs avec des cheveux longs temps
réel tout c'était génial parce que tous
les gens de la ville c'était à beaune en
bourgogne pour ne pas dire le nom de la
ville et puis tous les gens d'avis
disait mais qui sait c'est horrible leap
x tra et moi je trouvais ça génial
l'avait convoqué je trouve ces travaux
qui d'une certaine façon leur la bonne
petite bourgeoisie provinciale
exactement voilà alors au début donc
effectivement vous avez 8 9 ans et c'est
fou parce que moi aussi j'ai un fils
kaka 8 en voilà et donc le mec s'appelle
didier il est projectionniste dans la
troupe de théâtre qu'à monter votre
votre père mes parents à beaune et vous
raconter la première fois vous dites il
m'a fait la chose son nom circula on est
vraiment dans l'indicible c'est à dire
que vous au départ vous savez même pas
ce qu'est le sperme vous croyez qu'il
vous pisse dessus donc non mais c'est
foutu nation c'est à dire que vous ne
jouez pas donné de détails trop scabreux
parce qu'effectivement on est là pour ça
pour le lait c'est vrai que vous n'y
connaissez rien quand il commence non
mais pour pour le dire pour le dire
crûment c'est vrai que il me prend la
main il me la met sur sa et je sens
un truc mouiller je me dis il a
pissé c'est horrible c'est vraiment
dégueulasse enfin bon et
et
et ça prouve combien j'étais petit quoi
combien j'étais passé ce qui est
terrible en fait dans cette histoire
c'est que le plaisir que vous prenez pas
ce que vous prenez du plaisir vous êtes
bien sûr le premier à l'écrire aussi
clairement vous prenez du plaisir et ce
plaisir
génère chez vous une certaine
culpabilité parce que vous dites
finalement je prends du plaisir donc
vous avez un tournant de sa voix cette
passivité cette culpabilité vous amène à
ne pas en parler autour de vous ni à
votre père né votre meilleur oui et puis
alors il ya la culpabilité et puis elle
fait aussi que pour moi tous les adultes
sont un peu complice à dire ils sont
tous en vie ses amis vos pareils c'est
un ami de mes parents ils travaillent
tous ensemble et c'est donc à qui je
vais aller en parler ouais à personne je
vais pas en parler à mes copains de
l'école je vais pas en parler non plus
aux adultes puisque les adultes sont
tous ensemble qu'ils sont plus au
courant les c'est ça ouais alors
vos parents sont divorcés lui évidemment
il en profite pour s'immiscer comme ça
auprès des enfants et ce qui est
terrible quand on lit le bouquin c'est
qu'on se rend compte que vos parents
sont presque soulagé parce que c'est
vrai que c'est une époque très edonys
très individualiste très égotiste où on
se dit finalement voici s'occupe des
mômes tant mieux dans vos parents bon ça
veut rien d'abord et ensuite ils sont
pas mécontents que ce gala vous prennent
en charge non parce qu'il avait des tas
d'autres choses à faire mon père était
dans une sorte de vertige incroyable il
venait de fonder sa troupe sa troupe
avait un théâtre national d'un seul coup
de données par le ministère de la
culture il est plein d'argent il pouvait
monter tout ce qu'ils voulaient
britannicus now et cetera donc lui il
était parti dans son truc de théâtre
subventionné
comment on dit délocalisé enfin de le
de théâtre et puis ma mère elle l'avait
ses amants il fallait qu'elle refasse sa
vie etc mais votre mail à les soustraire
votre mère ce qu'elle est mais sait
séduire donc effectivement elle avait
toujours des mairies aussi faire le porc
au caramel
voilà alors avec ce didier bas vous
habitez vous vivez chez lui il achète
une maison pour vous une maison là et
vous vivez comme une espèce de petit
couple
toujours bas 9 en juin 2009 à 14 voilà
ouais
14 ans vous étiez en coupe ouais ouais
et ça c'est une photo qui a été fait par
le fameux dj derrière vous aider vous et
des photos à la main c'est un bon
photographe qui a fait une mauvaise
alors il en a vu d'autres qui sont un
peu plus suggests illicit ouais vous
n'avez pas évidemment mais c'est déjà
très gonflé en mettre une photo de lui
en couverture alors vos parents
remarquent rien mais en fait dans la
ville en remarque c'est à dire comme
vous avez les cheveux longs un peu tin
oo aînés vous avez des pantalons pattes
d'eph vous avez des chemises indienne on
vous traite de dans la ville on
dirait c'est le mais vous vivez ça
vous supporter ça bah ouais je suis
porte ça et en même temps ce qui est
terrible c'est que en même temps c'était
vrai ouais
en même temps c'était vrai quoi que je
me dis ben oui ces mecs là ils écoutent
sardou il écoute johnny hallyday moi
j'écoute frank zappa et david bowie
et je suis pas je suis pas que me quoi
il y avait un sentiment aussi la fin peu
à l'écart d'être mieux que les autres
d'une certaine façon d'être à la fois
mieux mais pas du tout avec les autres
c'était c'était super flippant c'est à
dire que j'avais deux copains pour tous
en tout et pour tout j'avais deux
copains et donc mes deux copains de 30
ans et ce n'est pas du tout d'accord
avec moi parce qu'il préférait la
maladie d'amour à demain finma ne frank
zappa donc
il comprenait pas pourquoi moi
j'écoutais cette espèce de musique
bizarre hein
ouais ouais enfin bon il faut lire le
bouquin je veux pas en dire beaucoup
plus c'est très bien écrit à cette idée
que vous avez un certain moment de
mettre des phrases entre parenthèses et
en italique et et on comprend que c'est
peut-être ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
en tous les cas c'est raide si un jour
vous découvrez que c'est vous qui le
tenait ouais et là c'est important d'en
découdre ils vous aiment qu'il est qu'il
a besoin de vous beaucoup moins que ce
que vous avez besoin de lui et vous
finirez par le quitter mais quand vous
le quittez vous êtes tellement détruit
par à part dans cet amour bizarre que
vous sombrez dans le lsd dans l'héroïne
bah non un nom à 15 ans à 15 ans ouais
non à 15 ans à 15 ans effectivement je
prends pour la première fois de
l'hérault du lsd plein plein de drogue
très différente etc et je trouve ça
super bon parce que parce que ça me fait
partie
je dirais pas qu aujourd'hui devant tout
le monde que c'est super bon mais pour
pour moi ça a été une espèce de oued de
libération en même temps je ne le
recommande à personne
sans la drogue c'est au début on en
prend pour être bien pu y apprendre à
bompas bien attendons concours pas être
mal et puis après on est très mal on
connaît l'histoire mon cher ami voilà
alors là vous vous demandez
effectivement est ce que vous êtes
pédophile parce que souvent les
pédophiles ou réplique est ce qu'un subi
ce qui était le cas d'ailleurs de didier
qui un jour vous amène sur les lieux de
son enfant et vous découvrez qu'en fait
il a été violentée étant enfant vit
peut-être que je suis pédophiles
peut-être que je vais refaire les mêmes
choses à des jeunes enfants vous tenez
vous vous demandez vous êtes homo vous
dit peut-être que je suis homosexuel
après toutes ces expériences et vous
vous rendez compte que finalement non
vous n'êtes pas homosexuel vous rendez
compte que vous aimez les filles et je
voudrais vous êtes mariés père de
famille faisait deux filles et comme
vous dites vous n'arrivez pas à leur
donner un bain parce que parce que ça
vous revient quoi bah oui c'est
impossible je le jeu peut pas toucher le
corps des enfants
cc c'est pour moi c'est trop quoi donner
un bénéfice est impossible alors quand
vous êtes dans la drogue un jour votre
père vient vous engueuler rusant
pourquoi tu prend de la drogue et vous
vous dites moi si tu commences tu es
occupé de moi il vous dira compte voulu
raconter voulu réinventer à votre père
est effectivement il dit j'ai
l'impression de t'avoir abandonné et l'a
donc votre père vous lui dites mais
votre mère en fait il ya très peu de
temps qu'elle sait l'histoire ya deux
mois qu'elle sait l'histoire voit il ya
deux mois que c'est l'histoire mais elle
a été elle était furieuse elle est
vraiment tombé par terre à ce moment là
elle a appelé ce mec on didier ouais ce
en lui disant on fait mois des aveux et
cetera je veux des aveux écrits et c est
donc ce mec m'a appelé avant chez moi et
donc il a eu ma femme etc enfin bon et
c'est vrai que lui
se fait passer pour le bon samaritain il
a un bac vous d'en faire et où il est il
et ça c'est un mec assez extraordinaire
non il n'y pas non non il n'y rien mais
en même temps il veut pas ne veut pas
aller en justice quoi je le comprends
ils vous voulez y aller en justice où je
crois que c'est prescrit
s'il est toujours dans l'entourage de
votre père votre père sait où il est non
c'est mon père sait où il est mais ça y
est il est plus dans toi je mon père
mais on a été longtemps trente ans après
donc vous arrivez enfin dénoncer on
comprendrait à lui pour vous en arriviez
là aujourd'hui pourquoi ne pas lui
refait de procès
parce que pendant trente ans j'ai caché
tout ça sous un mouchoir jusqu'à temps
que je me retrouve à sainte anne où il
est fou et
où là je me suis dit non mais tu peux tu
peux plus tu peux plus t'en empêcher de
de masquer quoi c'est pas une histoire
christophe jallet félix pour échapper à
sainte-anne grosso modo qua non mais
disons les choses ouais ouais ouais
ouais quasiment là je me suis retrouvé à
certaines plusieurs fois et donc
maintenant c'est stop quoi je veux plus
retourner j'ai mis mes envies de ces
rigolos une fois de voir les fous
regarder la télé et puis là tu es venu
leur parler tous enfin moi c'est marrant
mais deux fois trois fois un stop quoi
et là vous pensez que ce livre va vous
sortir de ça pour toujours c'est là que
vous avez en faire mais ça laisse un
petit cercueil de mots m6 un petit un
petit cercueil écrit avec des mots à
l'intérieur et puis maintenant je les
jeter dehors et puis le lit qui veut
quoi ouais bravo aux enfants ils liront
les bases du super g j'ai vraiment du
mal à leur expliquer ce que c'est parce
qu'ils y voient le livre alors ils
voient la couverture est plus lisse mais
c'est toi ouais c'est moi et
mais ça raconte quoi c'est une histoire
incroyable genre l'île au trésor non non
non c'est je vais t'expliquer donc je
dois leur expliquer demain ouais ouais
demain j'ai promis dur on trouve un truc
il faut il faut continuer
imaginez que qui vous regarde là didier
là vous auriez quoi lui dire saga votre
caméra d'un cache toi ouais ouais cache
toi arrête un cache toi le plus possible
donc arrête quoi et qu'il a continué
après vous bah ouais mais il avait déjà
dragué des copains à vous qui avez
refusé un oui ouais ouais ouais ouais
non mais t'es pas
c'était pas un amour fidèle un an + wii
en plus
obligé le dénoncer à la police que je
sois obligé non mais je reste voilà vous
son numéro de téléphone ou un os sous
son nom bien vous allez il s'appelle
didier non non je peux pas mais
mais non j'ai j'ai pas envie de le
dénoncer j'ai un procès ça m'aurait bien
fait plaisir un certain moment mais
maintenant ça y est j'ai écrit ce
bouquin
ccc ce qui pour moi et c c'est pour moi
une forme de une forme de procès et
c'est plus que ça c'est vraiment plus
que ça ouais voilà en tous les cas ça
arrive que je vous conseille très très
difficile à lire mais qui est bien écrit
et qui est très littéraire surtout ouais
mais au fait votre entrée en littérature
aussi ouais c'est bien ouais vous c'est
vrai moi perso je trouve qu'il s'en sort
pas mal quand même il avait l'air plutôt
que dans ses mains se trouve c'est pas
vu avant mais vous avez l'air bien non
ça va mieux ça va mieux
inca 12 ans
bravo merci christophe tison
il met
bcg grâce et une admission
et sauf disons
et maintenant j'accueille charles
berling
charles berling là vous arrivez vous
arrivez du théâtre des amandiers à
nanterre où depuis le 15 janvier
jusqu'au 15 février vous êtes hamlet
dans une mise en scène de patrice
caurier et de moshe leiser vous vous
sortez la de quatre heures de cm1 voilà
charles tu proviens question tu es passé
par où
la
86e bcct libre c'est elie parce que là
vous arrive et nous on est là bon
complètement des genres ici la neige
partie d'un couteau et dont vous arrivez
vous arrivez de quatre heures sur scène
vous est donné à fond ce dessin très
vite performance extraordinaire ce qui
fait ses achats de lait à nanterre
alors vous l'avez vous l'avez voulu vous
l'avez eu votre votre âme l'aide parce
que ça fait quatre ans que vous racontez
dans toutes les interviews je veux faire
un bled je veux faire hamlet je fermais
donc ça y est la wii maintenant je paye
non mais oui tout à fait oui parce que
oui j'avais enfin non si j'avais très
envie de le faire depuis longtemps et
puis moshe leiser et patrice caurier sur
des metteurs en scène que j'aime
beaucoup qui font de l'opéra souvent
beaucoup à l'étranger mais que je suis
leur travail et donc il ya quatre ans
s'est dit on va le faire ensemble et on
a volé ouais bon là on a réuni des très
bons acteurs de théâtre comme christiane
cohendy john ryding marc bodnar c'est
une coproduction avec le québec aussi à
le théâtre du nouveau monde qui est dans
le coup c'est la traduction de qui
excusez moi parce que je sens michel
déprats jean-michel voilà voilà sur
extraordinaire les gens sortent et 10
mais c'est pas vrai vous avez trafiqué
le texte c'est mot pour mot le texte de
shakespeare mais la traduction de jean
michel déprats et est belle parce que
voilà bonne question dans une ambiance
18 vous
savez way libération qui est un témoin
encore gelé à libération libération qui
est un journal pas toujours facile dit
charles berling se donne au personnage
de façon radicale est totale il invente
il construit il fait vibrer voilà donc
c'est le seul papier que j'ai vu sur la
pièce en tous les cas pour le moment
inaptitude autrement tous les cas oui
celui-là était extrêmement positif il ya
un truc qui n'aiment pas libération
c'est le décor ils parlaient pas et d'or
parce que lui parle de leader alors que
c'est bien je sais pourquoi les décors
c'est pour donner le côté comique de
shakespeare j'imagine oui parce que
souvent je veux shakespeare et en
particulier à melay tendance avec un
regard comme ça c'est romantique ça soit
héros à ces protestants comme ça au fond
de la salle qui décide qui déverse une
belle pensée nous on pense
qu'aujourd'hui pour faire cette pièce
nous touche parce qu'elle nous paraît
vraiment ancré dans 20 dans ce qu'on vit
est donc le décor est moche parce qu'on
ne sait pas qu'il est moche c'est qu'il
est il ne veut pas être bourg vient pas
de vous n'avez pas de bon
goût bourgeois d'aujourd'hui enfin veut
que le ca soit une idée de dames l'aide
qu'ils soient réussies joly est ou non
on a dit nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est ce qu'on ressent avec cette place
et et hamlet il faut bien regarder que
quand ils arrivent au début de la pièce
c'est vrai que ça va pas fort mais quand
il s'en va c'est encore plus terribles
justement bordel encore pour tout est
raté
que plus j'adore
on peut dire d'hamlet que plus il
cherche à agir plus il fout la merde ce
qu'est ce qui est trés ce qui est très
proche d'un héros moderne justement mais
c'est exactement ce qui se passe pour
tout le monde aujourd'hui tous ces
individus se disent même les plus
lucides pascal monette est très
intelligent très lucide mais les plus
lucides et se disent bon mais la
lucidité aujourd'hui ne sert plus à rien
c'est à dire que tout va on va tous au
cas où on a répété pendant la canicule
cet été à nanterre il faisait 40 degrés
il y avait une impression comme ça avec
cette canicule de côté aux primaires de
l'année prochaine c'est encore pire
tiens donc ça va très bien avec la pièce
et ça nous a ça nous a donné les leurs
il est parti à new york quand l'accès a
été alors là complètement le oui parce
que new york est une ville qui
deviennent de plus en plus folles ont
fait un plus quand on vient de paris les
petits provinciaux comme donc on essaie
tout d'un coup c'est hallucinant donc
donc cette débauche de 2,2 de choses
d'objets de sens c'est exactement ce qui
traverse la pièce est ce qu'ils
traversent hamlet qui ne peut se fier à
personne qui ne sait pas qui croire
qu'ils ne sais pas s'il a vu vos
bourreaux profondément moderne oui je
crois mais vraiment en tout cas moi je
me retrouve totalement je crois que rien
déroule enfin vraiment même fabrice et
pour les enfin aujourd'hui c'est en tout
cas le rôle le plus fort que j'ai jamais
pu faire la vie ça va par sa non la vie
ça va très bien je vous ai croisé
l'autre jour vous m'avez pas vu un seul
agent m'avait près mais je ne vis plus
en ce moment très mal j'ai croisé deux
jours avec j'ai croisé avec vos enfants
à saint germain des prés love city avec
un un garçon il file non c'est pas ma
fille il maintient ses images jeunes
fiancés mais les très jeunes alors que
sun je sais pas où l'aide s'est coupé
arriver à garder
alors on ne joue pas à bled par hasard
on va faire connaissance avec le côté
obscur de charles berling interview côté
obscur
[Musique]
ciao jeter obscures
depuis que leurs amis des fleurs là est
ce que vous avez déjà souhaiter la mort
de quelqu'un oui mais comme hamlet je
n'ai jamais pu le tuer mais ça m'est
arrivé oui est-ce que vous avez déjà
fait l'amour en ambre inter bah oui oui
1 avec 2 mai coup de fil ou non
vous savez beaucoup d'expérience donc ça
peut être deux mecs je vais tout ce que
vous voulez à nanterre il 100 pages de
ses troupes à quoi est-ce que vous
pourriez signé pas vous est ce qu est ce
que vous pourriez
vous le ba-ba women années soixante huit
mois est ce que vous pourriez s'ensuit
est ce que est ce que vous pourriez
signé un pacte avec tf1
un pacte avec cfm partenaires de la
pièce ne prend même pas la question
vous en voulez beaucoup vous dites aux
bourgeois bourgeois qui dirige la télé
est finement le mépris qu'ils ont pour
les classes populaires c'est de faire de
la télé de merde alors qu'eux ils savent
qu'ils font de la non j'ai besoin de
cultiver vos savoir qu'ils font là je
crois que certains qui font de la télé
vraiment de merde deux ont des
responsabilités voilà c'est ce que je
dis ça j'en suis sûr et je dis que ce
qui va nous arriver dans la gueule parce
qu'à un moment donné quand on commença à
en l'air la culture à en
l'air l'intelligence et la pensée des
gens on se retrouve avec des gens qui ne
pense plus qu'à une chose c'est prendre
une kalachnikov et vous tirer dessus si
c'est ça qu'ils veulent
c'est benjamin qui est responsable
certainement pas là bas si est-ce que
vous avez déjà été dépendant d'une
drogue
oui laquelle la cigarette ah oui c'est
fini la wii c'est courageux dit dans
depuis quand il est bien ce ver ling
cinq ans j'ai fait comme mon père parce
que là il m'a dit à 41 ans il faut
arrêter médecin votre père ben ouais il
m'a dit après la courbe et le monde
c'est à dire comme ça et à 45 pour
crever donc j'ai envie de vivre est-ce
que vous avez déjà baiser la femme d'un
ami me charles a certainement mais enfin
je l'ignoré
est ce que vous regardez on est toujours
un côté obscur est ce que vous regardez
les documentaires sur les poulpes
qu'est ce que ça peut arriver donc cette
attention c'est un signe ça faisait
quand on commence avec documentaire sur
les poulpes enfin je les chercheurs
savent c'est que vous cherchez pas si
vous aussi vous en voyez vous le
regardez ce que je vais pas acheter les
cassettes quoi je veux dire
non mais des gens ce que ça veut tout
contrôler c'est à la mode explique moi
c'est quoi le problème il parait quand
on regarde documentaire sur les poulpes
c'est un signe de dérangement à vous
mesdames dérange moins de quoi est ce
que moi je regarde si suc pas d'accord
mais il sait que les poulpes que les
pour que regardent les poules c'est
autre chose les méduses et les poules a
donc vous avez déjà regardé documentaire
sur les poulpes oui mais enfin le jpeg
gif toute une collection
je n'ai pas fait exprès ce que vous avez
déjà imaginer votre en terminale peuvent
ils oui ça m'est arrivé une fois parce
que j'ai eu un accident de plongée et
sur la remontée je pensais que j'allais
pas fine est présenté voyez le haut je
me suis dit j'y arriverai pas j'y
arriverai pas et là j'ai vu en remontant
j'ai vu mais j'ai vu tout quoi les
régions qui font emmerder les morts
qu'on voit ça on voit tout ce qui se
passe après on est ému même mais enfin
en même temps je ne suis pas arrivé
depuis toujours dans ton m il est
toujours ensemble et il est aux
amandiers noram l'aide merci
[Musique]
et maintenant bachot blind test
bien sûr en platine j'accueille jean
claude thin nasa
[Musique]
havas en mai venez mes amis
avant sont là
attention jean claude
merly
voilà donc un point pour l'équipe de
michael youn bravo
[Applaudissements]
ça
trois fois dans votre émission thierry
vincent a gagné deux fois je sais tout
seul je connais toi
[Musique]
une année
attention jeu god
merci
tiens
je suis fou
c'est
moi
c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
percy sledge bravo pour l'équipe de big
n
attention jean claude tu es prêt
attention à toi
[Musique]
voilà donc là alors là c'est un point
bravo benjamin morgaine dont j'ai bien
connu la mer tu sais que bercy explique
la mère quand elle dirigeait le jardin à
lampard n'ont jamais redirigé dans sa
mère dirigez de chardons des votes une
star sa mère alice morgan non mais c'est
vrai a dit ciaran c'est une star mais
oui elle danse elle faisait le jardin
des modes qui était un journal culte de
cul par de culte
c'est toi tu vois c'est nickel la maison
de course annoncions genre connaît
ça na waie
ça m'énerve
affaire de principe
et là c'est dur mais c'est je pense que
laurent baffie peut trouver celle là
attention jean claude
tu
benjamins 2
avant bravo bravo benjamin roger glover
du groupe i purple ou stabilise beaucoup
de pas avoir donné cette réponse parce
que c'est un standard et au volant le
clip est très bien en dessin animé là tu
vois on avait trop de points d'avancé
face à céder tout cas on est à 4 2 en
quête de sérénité c'est toujours de
vente est toujours devant attention
c'est très très très serré attention
jean-claude
[Musique]
replay khyber
attention riber
blues
[Musique]
ces deux égale à celle des crises
pourquoi nous mêmes explique la jeune
vieux bateau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le déminage on continue de plus en plus
difficile jean claude
[Musique]
donc on est à six molécules et michaël
youn et ouais ouais en tous les cas
attendent l'équipe de michael youn et
c'est ainsi pour moi j'ai une culture
moi dans mon enfance je faisais pas du
sud ou
est ouest désolé du recul
[Musique]
à
tous
m
voilà l'or par équipe chez l'équipe de
michael youn qui gagne 7 points
[Musique]
l équipe d'une alumina deux points mais
maintenant mais maintenant on ne rit pas
cette fois ci si massa bre nette
victoire au moins c'est chacun pour sa
gueule chérie vous êtes seul libéralisme
mais pourquoi c'est l'ultra hand est ce
que la vie est injuste et non mais si
mais si attention là maintenant il ya 3
il ya le banco le super banco le méga
banco
qui va remporter ce blind terre on
commence avec le banco jean-claude s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
chacun
m
[Musique]
monaco
le monde
attention mais thiery oui mais mais ne
me dites pas que ça s'arrête là mais non
via le superbe robe grenat
mais la vie est injuste vincent
attention mais je sais pas parce que je
travaille un petit peu allons-y au gpl
reconnaissent dans leur
île je suis estropiés
benjamin biolay
[Musique]
tu fais dans notre santé thierry javier
une paillette dans l'oeil nous étions
inquiets et benjamins de la shdm en
profitant de la monnaie java la non
objection projections nous demandons de
remettre la balle
non mais
c'est vrai nom elle est soit parce que
tu seras sauvé de la famille tout va
bien ça va ça va j'ai un truc dans l'âme
et chiens très le coup jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission maintenant donc alain chabat
a marqué donc le bon qu benjamin biolay
le super banco qui va gagner le méga
banco vous le saurez après
allez
[Musique]
le dire ouais
on sent
voilà donc laurent c'était tout le monde
en parle c'était tout le monde en parle
voilà c'est fini
j'étais moi aussi on s'est bien marré on
s'est bien marré c'était super merci à
toi oui oui eh ouais c'est toujours en
bas
ajilon
carmen ben le web des chiens chez michel
lafon
le single s'appelle comme des connards
alain chabat jean paul rouve pour le
film à rien alain chabat avec un sabbat
jean paul rouve maurice barthélémy
marina foïs
vernis pioche
martin laval pascal vincent sachant le
26 janvier mais les messieurs
le making of en papier dans le cabas
aux éditions les arènes
les peluches mes amis
pas non plus au foot
mohamadou
michaël youn vincent desagnat
benjamin morgaine les 11 commandements
par françois de saint gobain sorriaux
alias les real de madrid et louis
canning vincent desagnat et benjamin
morgaine et dieudonné
ça sort le 4 février
monsieur pénale et l'ina pour cours
camarade thierry bordas merci ma
nutrition
notre 6 4 benjamin biolay merci benjamin
djamel bensaber ligety voulait retourner
segal de paris mesdames messieurs
christophe tison son bouquin que je vous
conseille s'appelle qui m'aimait chez
grasset
charles berling arrête avec charles
berling gabriel arcand si j'avais le
briser
2 de nanterre en matière
emma votre
[Musique]
voyage en gros si mal l'album s'appelle
compilation berjaya volume 5
reporter sans frontières l union pour la
liberté de la presse est au prix de 8
euros
tant prisé dans le monde voilà c'était
tout le monde en parle je vous donne
rendez vous
mfg vous
sion
[Musique]
la mieux
oh
ok
non
[Musique]
on va
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu